development Control Committee a at mid
stop at District Council and can I first
of all just remind you of some of the
domestic arrangements for today the W
C's are situated outside the council
chamber just by the lift and the stairs
cold water is also available out there
in the breakout area if the fire alarm
does sound can you please leave the
meeting room or the council chamber
follow the fire exit signs and we gather
on the interest áown Football Club
training pitch and please do not
re-enter the building until we're told
it is safe to return kind of so let's
get one system quick look at your mobile
phones just make sure they are in silent
or switched off please we do have a a
gentleman's agreement if it rings we'd
like you to make a donation to the
Chairman's charity so if it does ring I
just remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings for those that they want to the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items which we do not have today
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consented to being filmed and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting so
long as the public and press are not
lawfully excluded and so can I just
remind members that when they speak and
to officers please remember to turn your
microphones on so that everyone in the
chamber can hear and can you please
speak loudly into the mics because we
have had reports in the past that people
up in the gallery can't hear clearly and
just for the benefit there's so many
members of the public here today you may
not be familiar with how and this
meeting will work I'm Matthew Hicks I'm
one of the district councillors and
myself and my colleagues here on my
right and front row between us we'll
make the decisions on the applications
before us today at mid Suffolk Council a
wall
member an Electra may not vote on an
application within their own Ward and
therefore when that happens they cross
the floor and you'll see on the left
hand side we have two counselors who
will speak on the applications but may
not vote on the applications before us
today we have a various officers who
will present the applications to us we
have Ian who's our legal adviser then we
have others that just make sure
everything flows when your time is if
you are on the list to speak you'll be
asked to come up to the front row
push the microphone and you'll have
three minutes to speak there is an egg
time and I'm afraid we do keep to the
three minutes if you go beyond it you
will be cut off so please do try and
keep to the three minutes I think that's
that's all the introductions for today
so moving on to the agenda the first
item on the agenda is apologies for
absence and substitutions do we have any
please Thank You chair we have two
apologies this morning of councillor e
Byrne and councillor Turner and two
substitutions of councillor Keith Whelan
for canceled reburn and councillor
Andrew Mellon for councillor Turner
Bobby thanks very much do we need to
receive any decorations of peculiar or
non peculiar interest by members and I I
just want just for the record to state
that I have funded the Stoneham a sport
football club for pitch works last year
so I just think just that that's clear I
don't think it's a peculiar non-punitive
just bread I just like to declare it
chairman you did sensibly before me
before today and it's it's a non
peculiar interest it was if I was from
your county councillors locality
locality budget right yes that's fine
thank you
any other members no thank you
do we have any decorations of blogging
yeah which item yeah we've all had the
same one yeah thank you any decorations
of personal site visits by members is
the next item on the agenda and
nope none spread okay item number five
on the agenda is the confirmation of the
Minister meeting held on the 11th of
December members have that before you if
I just run through each page and if
you've got any concerns or anything
you'd like to point out that you feel is
incorrect please just raise your hand so
starting on page two the seven about
papers 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 and 15
are you happy that I signed those is a
true record of meeting as that agreed
agreed
thank you I'll do that after the meeting
okay so back to the agenda at ICM agenda
number six is to receive notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme are there any
received none received you okay great so
we've moved straight on to schedule of
planning applications we will stay in
the order as laid out in the papers and
the first item is the land south of the
street strana mass for DC 1900 double to
double nine and over to you to present
thank you Thank You chair that screen
doesn't work before is we have a full
planning application for the erection of
46 dwellings including corrosion of
access provision of parking and play
space and provision of draining drainage
basin and landscaping we also have
improvements to Astana mashable Football
Club including the erection of a new
pavilion and creation of new pitches
now can we use can we use the mouse yeah
[Music]
there were policies for the technical
issue we've got the aerial map of Astana
Mossville here with the application site
shaded in purple you can see the main
body of the village running up here to
the west and then we've got stunning
barns down here to the immediate east if
we zoom in a little bit for though we
can see we have a road running down here
with under trees and if we look at the
constraints shown around the area
without the aerial mapping it's a lot
easier to see how the site relates to
the rest of the village we have a number
of listed buildings running along the
street once a particular note are here
here to the immediate northeast then
here to the east they are Chavez farm
and Chavez farm barn garden cottage and
ponds cottage they're all listed it
great - we have a number of public
rights-of-way that cross over the site
as well we have one running from the
south
roughly north and it also veers off as
well in the middle of the site and then
continues east if we look at the brown
line this is the existing settlement
boundary for Stan Massport and we can
see that within the current local plan
the site lies outside if we move forward
we have the excerpt from the draft joint
local plan including the allocation this
site we can see that the boundary of
Astana Baskerville has been redrawn in
this purple line here and we can see
these green areas they indicate that
they mated open spaces obviously at the
moment it's designated open space for
the football club that's currently on
the site and there's been the extension
of the designated open space here to the
south to allow for relocation of the
football club following development of
the site
then we have the red red line outline
here I'm showing the application site
and then we sell the blue line to
knowing land within the ownership of the
applicant and if we come here we
superimpose the aerial view of the
existing site zoomed in over the red
line site boundary which is shown here
in this dark line and sorry we here we
go can people hear me at the back just
so I'm okay so we now have the aerial
view superimposed on the existing site
we have the car park in off the a 1120
here with recycling facilities and then
we have the existing Club buildings down
in this corner of the site here if we
come now to the submitted landscape
plans we can see how the site would be
divided we would have built frontage
facing onto the street here with some
additional housing on the land currently
occupied by the pitches of the football
club with the Football Club moving so
we'd have erection of a new pavilion
here car parking and then we'd have a
new jr. pitch new full-size pitch and
training area along with the play area
serving the rest of the development on
the wider village
I've included this from the design and
access statement to just run through the
rationale for how the site has been
designed and developed we have the blue
land at the south that's the the
community land providing an edge of site
between the open fields and the built-up
area we have the purple areas which are
to provide by narrower streets with sort
of more irregular building lines trying
to mimic the organic growth that we see
elsewhere within stood on the basketball
and then we have the yellow area which
is the spine through the site so it's a
much wider road to provide the
connection through we've got homes
running parallel to it and we have much
larger
so we normally have as well to cope with
pedestrian access members we'll see from
the report that we've had a number of
comments from the highway Authority with
regards to the design for this
particular application I've just put up
the original site layout for information
so this refers to the first lot of
comments that we've had from the
Highways Authority they were
particularly concerned about the access
point opposite dose field the the nature
of the shared access and also want to
see some revisions to parking plots
within the site we've secured that
amendment we have a new access point
further away from those field Junction
and we've amended parking it plots the
relevant plots highways have come back
in and still pointed out some issues
with plots number 1 to 23 and 24 and the
need for improvements to the bus stops
on the street close to the site and then
we come to the final layout which
relates to the final set of highways
comments and we can see from those
comments that highways are happy with
the the parking provision provided
they're happy with the access and we can
move forward without and without holding
objection from them with regards to the
public right-of-way obviously we have
them crossing the site as mentioned
earlier and in terms of the site they'd
also need to be a separate process gone
through for the realignment of the
footpath along this yellow line shown so
it would take it around the edge of the
pitches instead of a cross and then
would still allow for connection to the
existing line of the footpath running
roughly north and then the veer off
would be around the top of the pitches
and play area and then through the site
on the provided pavements
the sites will be delivered in phases
with the first beingness outlined in red
so we'd have delivery of the first 19
units here at the same time as we have
the implementation of the sports pitches
to the south and the provision of the
pavilion is proposed in the report that
we would then restrict the development
of the final phase of the site until
such time that the sports pictures are
provided and can be handed over to
astronomers well FC so it wouldn't be
the case that we could have the
development without the benefits to the
Football Club we'd have to see the
developers to the Football Club handed
before we were able to complete the
development I've just included the roof
flight plan for 4 members the the red
roofs indicate two-story buildings while
the pink represents single storey
buildings and you'll see that there's a
predominance of bunglers provided on the
site in that's that the decision to to
utilize bungalow is more fully within
the scientists come about through
consultation between the applicants and
the parish council members of stone
basketball village particularly in terms
of what housing needs there is what what
preference there is for housing types
within the village we have two-story
fronting on to the street we're building
line is building height is predominantly
two-story we have a small section within
the site itself but the rest is is
single-story we've also got the slight
access planner apologies members I
wasn't able to trial the the
presentation before we got here so that
the the detail is a bit lacking we have
the site here to the south and we have
crew fueled Road running down here and
we have the street running through the
site and effectively showing that we've
got the sufficient visibilities players
running from both directions for me from
the access
we have the elevations of floor plans of
the Perot sports pavilion it's fairly
utilitarian and design but then given
that it needs to be a very functional
building I think that's that's perhaps
understandable
we'll then run through the house types
and I'll run through fairly quickly if
there's any particular house types we
want to spend a bit more time discussing
we can do in terms of built form
we've got other materials palette at the
end that I'll run through but
effectively the house types would be a
mix of red brick timber boarding and
render to a plus 1 to 14 or 15 3 and 17
4 and 26
and you can see often with reusing the
same house types occasionally but always
with the change of materials to give a
different feel to each individual unit
and if we look at the street scenes here
we have a view along proposed street
frontage here with the two-story
buildings and then we have a view of the
southern side of the spine mode which I
think gives a clearer indication of of
the final build of the unit's proposed
they've attempted in some ways to
replicate the vernacular seen within mr.
Donham as well obviously these are
modern buildings and it's difficult
sometimes to fully replicate historic
form I believe they're an honest attempt
to provide something I think they're
quite polite in their form and if we
look at the materials palette at the end
here we can see what they're what
they're attempting to do and I'll just
run through the photos as well of the
site one two again so here's the
entrance to the site from within the
site this is the carpark looking out to
the existing junction and then this is
the junction looking into the rest of
stone impossible note the the footpath
at the edge here connecting up so the
facilities within stannum Asheville
itself or within to 800 metres of the
the application site although it's
acknowledged that there is a continuous
footpath quite often anyone making a
pedestrian movement from this site into
the village would be forced to cross the
road at several points although at this
point the the a 1120 is at 30 miles an
hour if we look back towards stunning
barns which is following the road along
this way we can see a length of
continuous footpath here which then
terminates around the corner there's and
no further footpath connection from
Stone impossible through to ston and
Barnes anything that any any pedestrian
movements that side would be there be
made on highways verge or on the road
and be quite intimidating to pedestrians
this is the view from the entrance
towards one of the listed buildings this
garden cottage here with the thatch roof
this is a view along the northern
boundary of the site with existing
hedgerow and the existing recycling
center served an autonomous Ville FC
will just move closer you can just in
the distance here through the trees spot
gardens garden cottage it would come now
through the site moving around the car
park this is looking into the site we
can see the existing pictures in the
distance and then coming around again
have them here and then this is the Bank
of trees scene area lay down crow field
Road this is the existing pavilion
building set of buildings serving the
football club and these units here these
existing units houses sorry
served off the existing access from
looking the plans and layouts they'll
still be served by the existing access
and temporary measures will be made sure
and construction for the residents of
these units to continue being able to
access that house we now look closer in
at the existing clubhouse buildings
they're also prefabricated buildings so
we have the changing rooms and the
clubhouse itself and then if we just
backtrack here behind the clubhouse
buildings here you can't see it through
the dense planting here but that's where
Chavez farm and Chavez farm barn are
located as well
I'll pass things back to members in case
how many specific questions they'd like
me to address that I'm not right in the
report and then we can move on to
speakers okay thank you for the
presentation questions at this point
yeah cows are heading straight off thank
you
um what um trees and hedgerow are we
gonna be losing to any around the edge
of the site
so somehow if we go back into the
presentation just come back to the
landscaping plan for you
so we'll utilize it so the existing
dense planting here would be retained
and we'd also be retaining part of the
hedgerow running along the site there
would have to be a gap created but we
would have some infill planting to
strengthen that at the front as well
we'd also have some infill planting
within the site in terms of the
landscaping here and then again we've
got the existing hedgerow running on the
edges of the site at around the edges of
the field retained and down here and
then we'd have some additional planting
around the drainage basin here at the
very south of the site calamus thank you
I have a number of questions would you
like me to do them all at once or shall
I okay okay so first of all can I ask if
there are any of the affordable housing
I know it's a reduced proportion of
affordable housing but are there any in
phase one and could you also ask tell me
if there is the actual area of the
existing football pitches is the new
area for football pitches significantly
bigger or about the same and third
question in this batch is education
provision now in the papers it talks
about a contribution for transport to
school but is there no need for any
actual education provision financial
contribution so in terms of delivery of
affordable yes we've got a reduced level
of affordable housing coming forward as
a result of this development in terms of
delivery that would be governed by the
section 106 if we wanted to see delivery
within phase 1 we could try and see what
we could do to ensure that all four come
forward with in phase one I don't think
that would be an outrageous suggestion
from from the council in terms of areas
of the existing pitches we have a loss
of one pitch however we do have
improvement of facilities so our
policies regarding retention of sports
pitches and making alternative provision
for them do allow for where you're
losing sports pitches we should be
looking to regain an area of similar
size that's going to be of comparable
value but what we can also look at is
its where existing pitches are or where
existing facilities are less than the
community might not might need or the
sports club might utilize we can also
accept an increase of the quality in
terms of the open space so if the open
space is more usable is more it's better
suited to to the user that the football
club would make of it we can also accept
a reduction in terms of the space and in
terms of the pitch is provided we've got
a training area one full size adult
pitch and one full size junior pitch I
think at the moment there are two full
size pitches on the site so it will be
losing one full size pitch but then the
trade-off would be if the if the if the
replacement pitch was more more suitable
and enabled to me be made better use of
is that acceptable to members in terms
of the education contributions I'm just
going to try and see if I can get to the
new response from Suffolk County Council
in terms of what they'd like to see
[Applause]
which i think is page 60 something 69
yes so in terms of what they're looking
for
there are minimum people yields
associated with the development so we've
got eleven primary school-aged pupils
eight secondary school aged pupils and
then two pupils of six form age the
education Authority would likely making
sell bids on the back of the the
application to provide the addition
ality if place is required the only
thing that lies outside the realm of SIL
to provide is the transport costs for
secondary school pupils although we're
getting a reduced level of horrible
housing delivery on the site we will be
getting fulsol receipts for the forty
six dwellings so there'll be no loss of
sales so we'd be able to to mitigate
that need keep going I've got another
couple of questions firstly I'd like to
ask are there any plans to put solar
panels on the roof of the clubhouse in
particular ask a question about the
pedestrian routes Astana barns while
Sallah although I know this isn't part
of this application I vaguely remember
in the past that there was a suggestion
that's not the needful plan for mission
and condition five within the report
would require a I think you require an
outline of sustainability measures to be
utilized within the development and then
running of the site so we could see
further information come in there as
well
and could and could look to secure that
there with regards to the test room if
we can go back to the let's open up put
an aerial view in
so I think this plan would probably be
the best to show it so in terms of the
route into Astana Maskull itself there
is a there is a footpath in the entrance
to Stalin Barnes members might recall
there was an application site in here I
was looking to deliver part of that
route there is a site here it was
granted permission that's to provide
part of a route through the site this
then existing section 106 contribution
to make that final connection so in the
ends and in determining this application
there wasn't any way that we could give
to a potential connection to Stalin
Barnes although having visit the site a
number of times you do see people making
a walking connection there but it's not
one I would recommend hey can we start
the class amazing work along thank you I
note that highways initially had some
reservations about the recreational and
sporting facilities been off the same
access and what changed to allow them to
change their mind to accept that single
exit please effectively the applicants
have gone away and relocated the access
away from the junction at doz field so
we've got a better position within
within the road layout for the access
they've also widened that it's
significantly wider than it would
normally be the protect the the
pavements are wider than they would
normally be and in discussion with the
Highways Authority the Highways
Authority are now happy with that
relocated access giving a better route
through the site and one that they
aren't particularly concerned about in
terms of residential traffic meaning
potential matchday traffic in terms of
the residential users they mainly be
operating during what highways could
would consider to be peak hours for
vehicle movements whereas the football
matches themselves would likely be
saturdays sundays and then if you know
if the sports club had any meeting so
would normally be
outside of those peak traffic hours in
the evening anyway given the issues that
disrupt with Club have with parking in
the residential area around it are there
any proposals to put parking
restrictions on the residential parts of
the road to event some cars parking I I
think we could look into that as part of
the conditions to to the application I
think yes I think we would want to see
parking for the Football Club completely
housed within the parking provided on
site for the Football Club in terms of
the level of parking provided highways
are happy that that meets their adopted
guidance for the level of parking
required but I don't see any harm in in
in looking at TR Rose to provide you the
single yellow lines or double yellow
lines on that main spine road through
the site that would connect up and would
like to be the one most popular for on
street parking to access the Football
Club Thank You chair would you like mine
three at a time as well on slide 46 the
foot way along the site frontage seems
to be quite narrow it seems to be
narrower than at the sort of foreground
of the photograph do we know what width
the do we know what width of the
footpath is seems to be narrower along
that and I think that's the length the
foot a foot way that would be used to
get to the bus stops yes oh yeah looking
at it and having visited the site is not
1.8 meters which i think is its standard
now in highlights terms it is narrower
than that but then one would go to a lot
of villages within suffolk there might
not be a footpath at all so we do at
least have some provision it might not
be standard provision but there is at
least some provision I would say the
width of that footpath is fairly typical
of the width of foot paths with in
astana mass well in terms of making your
connection into the rest of the village
I think some might be slightly narrower
some
might be slightly wider just depending
on when they were put in but I think
that's a good general guide in terms of
how wide they would be it's probably not
wide enough that you would you know
comfortably pass so I'm pushing a
bicycle or with it with it with a pram
but I think that it's certainly wide
enough for two people walking opposite
directions to make a make a passing
movement without stepping into the
highway because you indicate where the
of the bus stops are pleased and going
back to the your previous answer is
their scope perhaps for achieving a
wider foot path along the frontage of
the site even if not anywhere else so if
we stay with the same photo for a moment
you can see one of the vertical flat
poles for the the bus stop here and if
we come further into the site you can
actually see it better just there at the
edge of the edge of the photograph so
it's not that far from the site itself
at all
in terms of the site frontage come back
to the the redline plan
we go into the frontage of the site
comes along along here so potentially
there is discussion that could be made
with the applicants to see if they would
like to widen the footpath in that in
that particular area but it would only
be within the scope of their land
ownership that we did able to be be able
to achieve that that's not been
requested by by the highway authority
though so it would be at their
discretion as to whether they wanted to
widen or not lots of all the junior
pitch is that is that much size Julie
seems to be too small for under under 16
I wonder if it's if it's there for sort
of under eights under nines or something
it is it a suit in shape and size it's
been described as a full-sized junior
pitch and consultation with sports
England hasn't found any deficiencies in
terms of their proposed pitch sizes do
we know where the floodlights would be
situated at this point I don't there are
existing floodlights on the site and I
think it would be useful if we utilize
conditions to secure lice bill diagrams
and positions of the flood lighting so
we can be sure we're not so we were sure
the wind not creating a light nuisance
or a light disturbance and further 1520
half an hour after after the end of that
session just to allow for clear up and
and and not from the route of the
services that connect Astana mass will
know and the frequency of the services
the 1 1 5 service I think is six times
daily at the moment and the the other
service I think is twice daily so it's
not a particularly frequent service but
no I can give no comfort as to whether
those services will be continuing in the
future that would be a commercial
decision for
the companies that run those services
you know if they if the if the bus
companies are making profit running the
lines then they will look to to either
stop running that the service reduce
frequency or pull out of running them
full stop but then that is a situation
for a lot of our for a lot of our rural
villages is that we don't really have
the certainty over how how frequently or
how popular the bus routes are other
than that time of writing yeah okay um
do we know if the balancing pond will be
wet or dry at the end of the storm when
it is joined will there be a retention
of water and do we know if the if the
drainage board had confirmed there is
downstream capacity for the flow from
the balancing point so the internal
drainage board agreement is separate to
planning the applicants will have to
have that before they begin so if the
drainage board decide that they aren't
going to allow them to make that
connection that have to come back to us
for further information in terms of the
submitted detail the flooding water team
at County Council are satisfied with the
detail the way the drainage basin would
operate is that in times of severe rain
flaw or flood the water would flow down
into the drainage basin and be held
there and then discharged over time into
the surrounding landscape so depending
on on the severity of the the flood
event it may be wet at the end of the
event but the idea would be the
graduating and quite it will gradually
reduce in level until the basin was was
clear as well
the landscaping plan suggests planting
within the basin so it dry times it
would just appear to be an element of
the landscape at wet times it would be
it would be it would appear as as a you
know
an opportune pond I suppose but the
planting proposed would be sufficient to
to deal with both that dry period and
wet thank you casa milà would it be
possible to ensure there are some
electrical charging points of vehicles
either in some of the properties or at
the new pavilion for the football club I
noticed in the papers it doesn't even
any mention of those at all yeah we
would normally deal with it that's a
detail of that through condition I'm
just having a look and we could utilize
that we've tie light into the
sustainability measures condition five I
think it's also one of the conditions
that the Highways Authority who have
mentioned as well so we probably
wouldn't do it twice however we roll it
in we do it but we could we could secure
electric vehicle charging points both
the football club and for the facilities
within the site itself no keep going
catamaran castor field Thank You chair
um I sort of got my head round the the
layout which is has moved to avoid a
sort of crossroads type entrance but
that pushes the entrance to the estate a
bit closer to the CRO field Road
junction and to the corner coming around
from stone and barns and I appreciate
this is in the thirty mile an hour limit
but do we have a speed survey that shows
the actual speeds on that section of
road not with this application no but
then the the thirty mile an hour speed
limit does begin further further along
to the to the east sort of not quite and
the junction of the eleven twenty with
East End Road but a little way before it
so we were well into the thirty mile an
hour limit there I note that the
discussions around highways and the
transport assessment do note two
incidents within the past five years one
at the junction with crow across world
and one close to the junction with East
End Road but investigations into those
accident both recorded that they were
due to driver error
and and were not indicative of
substandard facilities within the
highway themselves thank you I'm just
gonna point out on electric electric
vehicle charging points there is there
is a provision the fourth bullet point
up on page 38 of the fourth one about
three but it doesn't make any mention of
a witness actually cites the electric
vehicle charging points well guess
that's obvious but it doesn't actually
make any suggestions about the numbers
that will be included it could be just
one I mean is there is there a number
that members would like to see included
apologies member Helen just clarify
we're happy to conserve to put forward
the condition would be one per dwelling
and we had asked for a scheme in respect
to the pavilion and we'll see what comes
forward in that respect we've not had a
scheme for pavilion before so I would
ask Paulie for the details to be agreed
with the applicant on that basis but it
would be one per two Welling otherwise
as per normal which we have been doing
consistently for the last year or so
thank you
cows Somali you have a question do we
know what provisions we made for the
football club and where they're gonna
play whilst their field is being dug up
I'm not aware of any provisions at the
moment I expect the club will have made
provision for yeah of course I'm just
I've got the phasing statement and
development program before me and I
don't think that was in the papers I'm
not sure if it was in the bundle if
anyone can help me out it might help if
I quickly read the the statement in that
respect if you bear with me
so the phasing of the development is
proposed in two phases to avoid as much
you know to avoid disruption to the the
Football Club as much as possible
phase one would consist of the
construction of nineteen joinings along
with the construction of the clubhouse
community having sports facilities it is
invidious the completion of this phase
would take 12 months from the grant of
planning permission or from the point
that conditions are dealt with phase two
would construct would consist of the
construction of the remaining dwellings
and obviously this would not be
commenced until the new clubhouse and
sport facilities have been completed
again they envisage another 12 months to
complete that phrase that's what it says
here so that's what they put forward as
a phasing plan and that is conditioned
in your papers to follow that phasing
plan thank you
Castle William you've got more questions
or no you're happy yeah anyone else I
just asked about the football club I see
in the papers that the ongoing
maintenance of the car park and various
other things then I moved to the
liability of the football club and my
experience is that lots of these
football clubs you know and small
community clubs are living on a
shoestring just every year trying to
keep going have we heard from the
football cover that they are happy to
take on that liability
I I'm assuming the football club are in
looking into the application the
applicants estimates to be an named
Donna Mashable FC is the landowner so
presumably they are fully aware of their
maintenance requirement in terms of some
of the areas of planting they are
effectively left to be low maintenance
areas so the drainage basin wouldn't
really require a lot of looking over and
in fact actually you might in terms of
biodiversity want to leave it well alone
completely unstrained the pitches
themselves they're obviously well
equipped to to manager maintain I think
they'd also be taken on the maintenance
of the play area which to some degree
makes sense given its more within their
purview and and you know the the
District Council and isn't really taking
on maintenance of new player areas will
be looking for details of that as part
of the conditions and also secured
within the section 106
so we'd have full details of what
exactly was going on there and
presumably the football club would be
present during those discussions as well
any other questions or we can move on
okay so we're gonna move on now to hear
from the speakers first up is we have
Peter Emerson from astronomer school
parish council if you'd like to come up
and you get the three minutes please
good morning as a parish council we
needed to be consistent in our approach
and decision-making to this application
by applying the same criteria as we did
and have done with previous applications
within the parish therefore we objected
to this application on the grounds of
the size of the development which
effectively would increase the housing
in the village by between 18 and 20
percent the impact to nearby listing
buildings as shown on the previous maps
the fact that technically the site
currently is outside the settlement
boundary and also residents comments and
concerns regarding traffic through the
village having said all that the parish
council was impressed how the developers
went about creating the final
application they worked very closely
with the planners and Suffolk highways
whilst presenting their plans at regular
intervals to the parish council and
local residents inviting comments and
suggestions to support and enhance the
village going forwards in addition the
housing types and sizes are of benefit
to the parish and will encourage
first-time buyers and downsizes alike to
move to the village again supporting the
community in the longer term the parish
council also supported the development
of the sports facilities which we feel
is very important as they will
undoubtedly benefit the parish through
the use of the clubhouse the
reconfigured sports facilities has been
described as well as supporting the
development of youth sport locally so in
conclusion we objected but the parish
council certainly sees the merits of
this application thank you okay do you
have any questions for the parish
council yeah and do you have a village
hall outside of this development we have
a village hall which is at the other end
of the village and that is used on a
regular basis both during the day and
the evenings both locally and by groups
outside of the village s it has no
license drinks license can apply for
temporary licenses but it is well used
any other questions like I'm just gonna
put you on the spot bid because that's a
hard conclusion for us to sort of sum up
so it sounds as if you're torn between
the fact that it is such a large
development but obviously it's bringing
substantial benefit and so would you
want to guide the committee any more on
the parish councils overall here because
we we do take you know we took the view
of the parish councils the people on the
ground and the community again it's a
very difficult difficult thing I'm chair
of the parish council I have a personal
view and I have to remove that personal
view from the from the parish councils
view the parish council sees great merit
in it which is why I've spoken today we
did object but we see great merit in it
because we want to keep the village
alive you want to keep it moving
forwards as do the developers we believe
what we object to or is is the principle
that it's a large development but it
needs to be a large development to
support the aspirations of the Football
Club we also have concerns that this may
set a precedent for the future now I
know that the planning decisions are
made in isolation perhaps however we
don't want as a parish and as residents
for the village which is over a thousand
years old to suddenly become a small
town and this being the start of a
development development development
development so that for us is a concern
this in isolation we feel would
effectively build out the village and if
you could if you could promise across
your heart and hope to die that there
will be no more development once this
development have gone through then
perhaps you know we would we would be
satisfied with it it's a very difficult
and we're we're I think we're all
sensing your what you're saying yes it's
a it's a it's a real balancing act for
the community I can see yeah because
you've been giving something various but
it's not a straight objection that we
don't want no Civil War lay down in the
street yes and stop the Bordeaux's yes I
think that's very well explained sir
thank you for that that's rays but yes
sir
do you want to have a question just a
very quick question um the the clubhouse
would presumably have a drinks license
would it be the only place in the
village that has a drinks license and
would you expect that it wouldn't be
just footballers who would be using the
clubhouse but it would be more of a
social club I can't answer the question
with regards to the drinks license
concretely but I believe it will have a
an alcohol license it is the only place
in the village that has or will have a
drinks license the village hall can have
temporary licenses but that's a there's
no other facilities my belief and the
parish councils belief is people were
migrated to the clubhouse and use it as
a more of a community hub and that is
that is the hope that it will be used as
a community hub and then you have it
then develops from there that that's my
opinion I haven't spoken to the Football
Club to say that is what they will do
but ambitions about the licensing when
they got no but we've got the applicant
so they they're next that is my that is
my hope and an aspiration for it okay
thank you very much other questions
thank you
so next up we don't have an objector we
don't have a supporter but we do have
the Agent Andrew Salas so if you'd like
to come up please and again if you could
keep to the three minutes please
firstly I'd like to thank the chairman
and members for the opportunity to say a
few words in support of my client's
proposal and to thank the officers for
the thorough recall and for their
constructive approach both pre and post
submission of the planning application I
was from the outset pleased to be asked
to promote this development as having
been a planning consultant for over 30
years it's a fine example to me as to
what planning should be about delivering
much-needed development in a way that
brings substantial benefits to a local
community it is a proposal that not only
provides much-needed housing but also
provides a significant improvement in
sporting recreational and community
facilities safeguarding enhancing the
future of Astana Mashable Football Club
first the proposal provides a mix of
small and medium sized dwellings not
exclusive or executive in the modern
parlance but good quality well-designed
homes that will appeal to and can be
afforded by a broad cross-section of the
community the proposal also includes for
affordable houses specifically designed
to meet the identified need first on
them as well as advised by the housing
enabling officer in pre application
discussions second the proposal provides
for enhanced sport and recreational
facilities including new pitches
training area and a sports community
building without the provision of these
the Football Club will likely fold as
explained in synonymous upon FCS need
statement which accompanies the
application the provision of these
high-quality facilities will be a
significant benefit to the local
community and the applicants and the
Football Club believed that the club
will be able to enhance its role within
Stonem as well particularly through the
encouragement and expansion of its youth
teams and opportunities to increase
participation it's hoped that residents
and the many community groups
within the village will become involved
in the club and also making use of the
new facilities the sports community
building will provide a modern welcoming
and functional space for community use
and the applications are keen to deliver
the substantial benefits of the scheme
phases delivery to ensure that football
activities can continue seamlessly and
that the new facilities come forward
promptly I therefore ask members to
accept the offices recommendation and
grand planning commission for this
exciting development thank you very much
and I've got a question for off with
could you just and you talked about the
football club's you know being up
against it at the moment how do we come
you sure the committee that giving them
all this extra liability in terms of
running a building more you know take
you on a car park how are we going to
how can we have confidence that's not
going to appear again in 12 months when
they'll suddenly say we'll hold on in
the same position here is any confidence
you can give that this is going to give
them longevity I think it puts them in a
completely different situation visibly
Sport England and the ability to obtain
grants ongoing in the future I mean at
the moment they can't obtain grants from
any of the sporting bodies because
they've not got a permanent building so
that will be a quantum leap for them
that we think and they believe will help
them to sustain themselves for as far as
we can say the foreseeable future
this is the key bit thank you any other
questions casa master thank you um I've
got one question that hasn't arisen from
other bits of the discussion and that is
what is the sort of catchment area for
the participants of sonim a school
football club is it mainly in Tucson
basketball or do they come from the
wider community
and with reference to some of the other
questions that have already been asked
this morning I just like to know what
your yours and the applicants views are
on the suggestion of solar panels
charging points pavement widening and
having the affordable in phase one okay
I think in terms of of where the club
draws its players from I think at the
moment quite a considerable number do
come from outside Stoneham that's I
think primarily because they have been
run you know adult teams and that's what
they've done for many years but the I'd
the whole idea of this proposal is that
they they build on their youth teams
improve their youth team involvement and
that that in itself will engage more
with the ston Abascal community we've
got a you know school in the in the
village so there's real opportunities to
get the youngsters involved in the club
you get the youngsters involved you get
the parents involved you you have a
wholly different animal in terms of what
the club is so that's that's the club's
aim the solar solar panels and the
charging points we all know where we are
in terms of the environment today so
it's not something that the applicants
or the clubs are going to resist
obviously because it's the way that that
everybody has to be so where we where we
can put the solar panels we've got some
good south-facing slopes within that
scheme and on the pavilion itself so no
no issue with that at all charging
points again it's it's something that
responsible developers are
you know putting in unfortunately ayack
fur you know responsible developers so
yeah was there another it was the having
the affordable dwellings in phase one
and there was also some mention of
increasing the width of the pavement
across the frontage of the site
yeah well they the footpath does get
actually widened at the junction so
there is an improvement in terms of I
think two meters in terms of the width
of the footpath in the immediate
vicinity of the access so yes audibles
putting there in face model they they
can't go in phase one because phase one
hasn't actually got in the affordable
Zin it because you can see how it's been
bad there's nothing to prevent the
affordable coming forward before let's
say the 25th dwelling is occupied or so
it so it's easy to bring those
affordable Zinn right at the start of of
phase 2 yeah
very easy yep okay any other questions
yes cancer field yes just really about
the issue of foretelling the future well
we built are there any other sites in
stone or in our local planet as its
emerging I'm not familiar with the
pictures of that particular village this
is this is the only site allocated
within the emergent or local plan with
in Astana most of all now the questions
for the parish council sorry for the
agent No okay thank you very much thank
you
so we now move on to the ward member
councillor Suzie Morley over to you
thank you Jeff I have a big concern
about the width
about the width of the footpath along
the frontage of the site it's a very
narrow footpath and it's it's right on
the edge of the of the curb and for the
lorries that go down there their wing
mirrors are just at head height so given
the nature of this development is likely
to be young families walking to the
primary school I do have a lot of
concerns about that at footpath and if
it could be widened such that people
could walk closer to the hedge line as
opposed to closer to the road line that
would be a real benefit to the whole
village but having said that I really
like this development I've been really
impressed with the way the agent has
engaged with the parish council and the
residents I think it will be a fantastic
benefit to the religion and I fully
support it thank you any questions no ok
so members we've had all the information
put before us we've heard from the
parish council we've heard from the
agent we've heard from the ward member
it's up to us now to discuss debate and
to come to a conclusion can I just ask a
question we've heard the footpath
mentioned quite a few times the Suffolk
highways are saying that they're content
with the existing how could we as a
committee deal with that could we put in
a suggested can would have record it in
the past
a informative note that's the word thank
you informative note on that if we if we
go down that direction or how can we
pick up some of the concerns if you
don't mind if I just pick over this
slightly when we talk about this
footpath we're talking about just within
the site frontage of the application
site Yeah right
okay and in terms of this is where I'm
gonna ask down a few questions in terms
of the footpath for along the frontage
of the site only all of that is within
the ownership of the
and redline so as I'm and this is a full
application so we have layout as part of
the discussion appearance and so on so
it isn't like an outline where we can
cleanly come to this later you know this
is what the proposal is so the footpath
is commonly set out how wide is it just
to confirm I don't know how wide it is
but from being on site and walking it
doesn't appear to be full width as
required by standard but then it was
implemented prior to and this is my edge
of the voter so the concern here is the
way that cars boys and so on travel
through and I haven't gone up and down
that road many times in the last 15
years
I do appreciate their point every single
front garden as I look at the layout
plan has quite a reasonable frontage to
it I don't see there any harm in looking
at pulling back potentially that path
either keeping the same width but
pulling it back by half a meter or so
just to give that extra but you'd have
to take up a hedgerow mmm yeah so
there's a hedgerow the way there but
then we're dealing with the frontage of
these gardens anyway so there's a
compromise discussing debates your
members think I mean there is a
compromise because the problem is
there's a hedgerow there so to widen the
footpath you're gonna damage the edge so
we can whatever we do okay it's none of
us it might be we if it is the let's go
for the debate I would suggest but if
it's the only thing that causes a
concern it might be something we can we
delegate us to resolve before issuing a
decision potentially okay all right so
we've got some hands up the strap down
there first councillor mayor regarding
footpath I was like inserting my mind if
the width of the footpath were wider
along the frontage and it then narrowed
are we not introducing a an issue there
in the people on a nice wide footpath
chatting away they don't realise that
it's narrow will be not be better off
have the footpath the same width or wear
long yeah Castle William chair thank you
when we look to the photograph it seemed
to be narrower along the frontage than
it was in those sort of foreground of
the photograph so I'm at what I what I
would suggest was if we could achieve a
1.5 meter foot footpath which is not
much of a widening but it is it would
1.8 is the standard yeah I know but in a
rural area 1.5 would would just about
allow a buggy in each direction to pass
and for most of the length people would
be able to walk at the back of the
footpath so rather than me one point
back can I suggest with it because we
haven't got the measurement here we
don't know how much we've got between
the green area let's debate it if the
footpath is the number one issue we
could put a Advisory note in there that
we feel the foot push rewind to a
minimum of 1.5 meters
ideally 1.8 that to a minimum provoke
habit as an advisory note because it's
very difficult for us here today to
really know what's there and we need
some experts out measuring and then we
thought we're very clear in our
messaging by putting an advisory noting
and then we leave the officers do and if
the officers are unable to secure that
then we want to hear back or something
like that so that it doesn't just get
lost in the wash
might be a way forward yeah but we've
but we haven't reached any conclusions
yet we're just we're strong
yes Council having a well I'm happy to
um I think it's a really good um
application I think they've they've
engaged with the community they've
engaged with the parish council you know
that there's a lot of single storey
houses there and so I'm happy to propose
that we um go along with the officers
recommendation approval casa milà i
would like to support councillor
Hannigan's a proposal however i do have
reservations about the football club
taking on full responsibility for the
management
and repair of the whole site including
the carpark basically as someone who
chairs the CIC who has a football pitch
and I've known the issues that football
clubs have had trying to raise funds as
the chair reiterated earlier but apart
from that I do have to support it I
think that the the fact that the
residents the village had been sort of
consulted all stages as well as the
Parish Council it'll be a great
investment for the village it will
improve it considerably for facilities
etc so I do fully support it I'm told
that there is a footpath on the other
side of the road that is wide enough
just so that we're aware don't if you
look at the other side the road there is
a footpath that meets the width so
anyway okay so council mouse we were
next thank you first of all I would like
to thank all the people who've spoken
about this application because I I had I
had a number of queries about it and and
I'm a lot clearer in my thought
processes so I'd like to thank everyone
including the people speaking from the
public gallery it's been quite helpful
to have all that information and I am
very pleased to hear the parish council
say that they they thought that the
applicant had a swell with them I think
that is lovely to hear that because so
often we don't hear things like that I
did have quite a lot of doubts about
this application but having heard from
from all the various parties I think
perhaps it is actually a suitable
development for stole amass ball I have
concerns about the pedestrian
accessibility and you know if it is
possible I mean that that photograph
actually I mean maybe it doesn't give it
justice but it looks like a narrow
pavement that is slightly overgrown at
the edges anyway which makes it even
narrower so if there is any way it's
possible to widen it I would welcome
that I would also welcome a condition I
know there is a condition about
sustainability measures but it's not
really mentioned
report and I would like to see some
solar panels especially put on the
clubhouse you know and possibly charging
points and possibly solar panels or some
of the dwellings the officer did say
they could be fitted at a later date but
everyone knows it's so much cheaper to
put them in when they've been built
rather than retrofit so I would like to
see those in I would also like to see as
mentioned by the agent that if there are
no affordable in phase one I would like
to see some condition about the
affordable being like the first bit of
phase two because it's always one of the
worries for a community that they get
the development and then the affordable
czar never built and this does suffer
from having a reduced proportion of
affordable in it anyway because of the
viability issues so I would like to see
some a better guarantee that those
affordable are going to be provided
sooner rather than later so you know you
know all in all I am in in favor of this
development but I'll just wait to hear
what anyone else is saying I'm not sure
it has been seconded yet anyway
oh it was sorry I thought you just said
he supported it okay so we you know with
with those provisos about some perhaps
some stronger conditions and more
conditions
I probably happy to support it so I'm
just going to ask John to comment about
the solar panels and with reference to
the fact that it's already in here where
it says outlined sustainability measures
just so we're absolutely clear in terms
of the solar panels if members so wished
to specifically because of course what
he's asking for is a scheme but if you
if your intention is to ensure that
includes solar panels we can adjust the
wording to that effect so that any
scheme that comes forward to be agreed
includes a degree of affordable a degree
of solar panels that we can do that's
really straightforward just picking up
on the affordable housing point a little
bit of caution because I don't know how
the viability works in this game
I haven't looked at the liability
assessment so I don't know if putting a
trigger point in would upset any kind of
capital flow of money or what-have-you
but it is not unusual that in within the
106 agreement for the affordable housing
that we would have a trigger point based
on the number of houses constructed so
in this case I would suggest 30 would be
the best point to assure that viability
isn't affected I hope that's a safe
position to go forward on it is round
about 50% normally of developments where
we put forward the affordable housing to
kick in and I wouldn't expect anything
less here so I would if you're looking
for us to pacifically to find a trigger
point rather than leave it to the
lawyers ultimately then I would suggest
around 30 houses would be the point I
would ask 46 units in total for
affordable unit all for 30 market units
can be occupied before before before we
could reduce it down to 25 but I don't
want to get into it so in terms of the
phasing 19 units would come forward as
part of phase 1 along with the sporting
facilities no this suggestion is that we
would all be open market because they'll
be used to cross fund the development of
the sports pavilion in the pictures in
terms of the affordable units we could
look at 25 units so that there is one
open market unit delivered on Phase two
before the affordable units or we could
look to give greater leeway and say
you've got provision of the for
affordable units prior to the occupation
of the 30th unit of those options
legally yes I would probably lean more
towards the 30 because just to allow for
any unexpected issues but 25 is an
opportunity pembers want to take that
forward I leave that with members yeah I
mean I think we've got to be careful
we've heard the viability is tight here
we don't want this to loop the things I
mean what's up the proposal in a second
or what would you be happy with 30 I'm
happy with that yeah okay
well I saw the applicant nodding at 30
so and looking bit less nodding at 25 so
I think I think that's the indicator
yeah counsel well I'm sure I'm not quite
sure where we are with the 1.5 or
whatever footpath are we are we able to
put that in as a as a condition I put in
an advisory note that we would like to
the footpath at a minimum of 1.5
[Music]
are you happy with it being an advisor
in a 41.5 is proposed for a second oh
yeah is there anything else members
would like to discuss before we go to a
vote could I just ask are we leaving
these sustainability measures as as is
or are we going to put something and I'm
not sure whether the proposals seconder
but we're just going to dance it's going
to gate we're just going to get through
the recommendation check everyone's
happy and then take a vote so the
recommendation is laid out on a page of
our papers on page 38 and 39 with the
additional points that John's now just
going to read out so as recommendation
with the additional offering from member
from officers which is electric charge
just to clarify electric charging would
be one per dwelling and a scheme for
charging for the sports [ __ ] their
football club Pavillion to be agreed so
that's the charging sort of things we've
got a trigger point that's been put into
the 106 in respect to all 30 dwellings
and I've got a visor II note for 1.5
meter foot path frontage to seek to be
achieved I the solar panels I don't know
if that was picked up as as I would have
Barbie yeah I'll be happy for solar
panels to be part to your condition
where am I on foot oh yeah the fifth
bullet point down takes outline of
society measures of utility under
construction and incorporation of
renewable energy and sustainable
measures in the use of the dwellings and
we want to add to that line include that
shall include solar panels is that and
the pavilion okay yep that's fine so and
show ya been shown include so that's all
I've got so far so I think that's clear
for everyone so we're going to go to a
vote
all those in favor of the recommendation
that's just been read out along with
those on 38 and 39 of our papers we have
a show of hands that's unanimous
thank you very much thank you okay so
we're now going to move on to item 7 P
which is the application in DC 1902
double six
outline planning permission of five
dwellings and associate Guerra to Victor
access on the southside of rags Lane
warp it
[Music]
okay and over to the officer to present
Thank You chair good morning everyone
I will present you the application today
for land on the south side of regs Lane
in Woolpit the application is an outline
application including access and layout
we don't normally have outline
applications include a layout this one
does so just start on a large aerial
view so obviously this is Woolpit area
and the site there is just itched in
purple I'm just zooming in a bit further
we can see that this built form of sea
to the north we have two houses or three
houses sorry along this part and another
one here on this side of the corner we
have built form that runs along here
trying to get used to the mouse here all
the way up to this part of the corner
here there is one dwelling there and
that's a line ribbond development all
the way to the center and we also have
some housing here so just so no one's
confused this is actually excuse me
this is rags laying here that runs along
the north part and this is drink stone
road that runs along the seven southern
part showing a constraints map we can
see in the lighter purple on the
right-hand side of the screen there that
is actually the conservation area of
orbit and this darker line that follows
along here around the back of the
dwellings I pointed out previously and
along the front of the site and down
this side capturing those three
dwellings there is the settlement
boundary of warfare I'd also like to
indicate at this point as well that the
neighborhood plan incorporates the site
as local green space but the
neighborhood plan at this stage is at
very early pre submission it's due to go
to examination on the 7th of
February we'll come back to that in a
little while this is a block plan of the
layout of the site so we have two
drawings at the front we have two
attached garages served off and so
improve access that side we have an
access on this side for vehicles off the
drink stone right and then have three
other dwellings further into the site as
the road meanders round with a bit of
green space along that side of the road
and I've just indicated there with an
arrow because it's not quite clear we
will zoom into it in a little while but
there isn't a cycle and pedestrian
access only on two regs Lane and the
reason just to highlight at this stage
the history of the site some members may
be aware we've had a refusal on this
site for 60 and 45 dwellings previously
the main reasons for those refusals was
that raggs Lane could not support
pedestrian and cycle usage for that
number of dwellings highways are now
very satisfied around five dwellings
regs Lane can support the pedestrian and
cycle usage on to regs Lane and I will
just skip back to that actually I will
go into a little bit more detail there's
some annotations down here these are to
do with some improvements along rags
sorry drink stone Road and again we will
zoom into that and a little bit further
into the presentation so I've put a
picture up here just to indicate and
there's an arrow you see a lot of this
as we go through the slides that point
of the arrow is where we're kind of
facing so give you an idea of where
these photos are taken this is inside
the sort of centered on the left-hand
side just behind where this picture is
taken is where the coop is and this is
the entrance into rags lane here so this
is where pedestrians and cyclists would
emerge from we're going to wrap around
and see the front that is the the same
entrance that we're just seeing of rags
lane and you can see why 60 houses or 45
there's a bit of a pinch point in there
we can understand why we wouldn't want
that many cyclists and pedestrians
walking down there that just shows this
where that exact pinch point is and
we'll just move further along as you can
see with the arrow where we're facing
down and rags lane here so we just move
a little bit further so that we've got
just the left-hand side of this hedge
Road is the penultimate dwelling and you
can just see the driveway there of the
last Wehling and then the start of the
hedgerows of the north side of this site
here and that's clear that's just pretty
much exactly where we were but doing a
180 and looking back up towards wall bit
you can obviously see the church spire
there in the distance so we've just got
on the other side of the north side of
the site and again looking back towards
Woolpit
and this is pretty much where the
pedestrian access would be would be
inserted into this part here so any
pedestrians or cyclists those proto's
we've just seen would use rags lane to
get into the services available in the
center of all pip so is then just zoomed
in a little bit further that is the
pedestrian and cycle access and if I
just skip back if we just note that tree
there from my site visits I believe that
to be that one so it's just going to be
on the left-hand side of that tree there
we've got the two larger ones there and
one just to the right here so that's
just going to go next to there
so further along rags Lane looking back
across the site as you can see where the
arrow is and the top left there and you
can start to see the dwellings that
quite prominent on this area here and to
the right-hand side we've got the bench
hedgerow which formulates the northern
side of the site as a whole so the next
set of photos that will take you through
is a long drink stone road so just to
indicate here that we have the passing
Bay introduction here is at one part of
an improvement
we have localized widening of drink
stone road around here and we have the
tapered widening of drink stone Road
which is associated with the access
point into this side and just on the
other side of the access again we have
the tapered widening which allows for
the access the access these red
hatchings here note the visibility
displays but what we'd normally see in
an access is that we just come out
straight like this but we can see here
that with this tapered widening we have
an improvement to drink stone Road and
that's to 5.1 meters and then just to
add on the last bit there there is an
existing and we'll see a photo in a
second of a passing Bay there but it's a
bit of a muddy one so we will be
improving and formalizing that under the
section 106 agreements I haven't skipped
over the hedgerow and everything else
this will come later on in my report
because this is one of the main
considerations as part of this
application so just to look along during
Stone Road we can just see the roof of
the first house here and we'll move
along this is an existing site access at
the moment which is yet like say half
way along there they're not utilizing
that that's that will look to be stopped
up and a new access input in further
along so it's only to do with that
purple hatching as the site you can see
here that there is an existing passing
bay there that will be used to use some
of the formalizing of the widening of
the road as indicated earlier and I've
just kind of shown there this
this photo was taken back in June 2019
the application has been in the caseload
for a little while just so you can see
this was literally taken on Thursday
last week we can see the significant
difference of what it looks like in the
winter months compared to what it looks
like in the summer months and again this
will form some of the more detailed
analysis that we have about the
hedgerows as a whole I'll come to that
so we've got on the other side a drink
zone now right now and we can see that
these are some of the dwellings that
come out with drink stone so what we can
see here is we've got a few dwellings
here we've got some paddocks where this
photo is taken here and then we've got
the overall meadow here which has got
the hedge roll on the front and then
more dwellings this side so we can quite
clearly see that this is a very
transitional period out of Woolpit and
into the wider countryside open
countryside so houses paddocks meadow
houses we can see that that is a
transitional phasing out of the
settlement we can just see here as well
there is another passing bay here this
is the one that was indicated to the
right-hand side of the access that will
be formalized at the moment it's not
formalized passing bay so we've got some
improvements along during Stone Road in
terms of the highway and again on the
left-hand side you can see that we do
have on the photo at the bottom here
left-hand side we can see that we've got
all these open countryside fields and
the right hand side we have very large
trees hedgerows that make up part of the
character that goes out of Woolpit
and again this photo June 2019 and the
winter one just to give you a really
good indication of the difference of
what we're looking at again these photos
were taken Thursday last week these ones
in the summer so you can see what we're
looking at them so this was additional
information that was requested from the
council and we asked all those hedgerows
to be surveyed in a lot more detail I've
just noted at the top there please
ignore the red outline that red outline
does not
to know where the development is for
this site that red outline was put
forward as part of their orbit culturist
rapport and I don't think they've got
that red light brown correct but that
doesn't affect the development anyway I
just don't want anyone to get confused
with that so please ignore that red
outline plan hedgerows in these blocks
are the parts that have actually been
surveyed so h1 quite clearly shows there
that's where the access is pretty much
going to come in the report came back to
say all parts of these hedgerows our
plasters important hedgerow so that has
a certain number of species within it
and is then suitable as a habitat all of
the hedgerow along this side is going to
be retained other than where the
pedestrian and cyclist route coming into
here all of this is going to be retained
and as you've seen and we will just
quick forward in the second part of this
hedgerow is going to be lost for the new
access and tape it in there or culturist
report does ask them to at the front
here where the tapering takes place to
try and retain as much as that back
scrub as possible as a result of losing
that important hedgerow I felt it
important that we asked for compensation
without that compensation this
application could quite easily be
refused as a result we have now got some
sections of new planting obviously at
the front which will mitigate their
character loss in terms of that hedgerow
and also new habitats in there and as
you'll notice on there it does say to
retain where possible and along there a
very important feature which I think
most people will be happy to hear this
red line all the way along here is a new
native species hedgerow to be introduced
you'll notice that that goes round the
turning head so I think there was some
talks of objections that this would then
open up into the site and about allow
more development well if we've got a
compensated hedgerow that goes right
round that it's going to be very
difficult for them to remove that
hedgerow in the future because that will
be secured as part of a section 106
apology compensation
and then in more more interesting this
whole blue area here is going to be put
forward as meadow I understand that
obviously at the moment the application
site is a meadow so it might seem a
little bit weird while we were allowing
a meadow to be replaced with a meadow
but the difference is is that this one
will be able to be secured as a section
106 there's ecology compensation because
it lies outside of the red line plan but
we've inside the blue area and at the
moment the current meadow land that's
there existing at the moment has no
protection on it that could be flattened
any day now and so that that secures
that's the difference between the meadow
types that we're going to have some kind
of securing as a legal agreement and as
part of the condition that would be put
forward which I will come into and again
in a second is as part of the reserve
matters our colleagues at play services
would like to see a maintenance
condition put on that so we understand
exactly how that meadow is going to be
maintained and looked after in the
future and that'll be conditioned such
that they would have to do sort of thing
so if you've got a couple of photos
within the site as you can see it's very
overgrown scrubland
literally that's where the photo is
taken and you can excuse me just see the
tops of the houses there which are the
houses that sit right on that corner
that will abut this the development area
and again because I was out there again
in the summer that's exactly the same or
similar area where I've taken the photo
from and you can just see there so all
of this back dense shrub hedgerow there
will all be retained because that's this
area down this side obviously where
these houses are going to go this will
be cleared but then behind me where this
photo is basically been taken from we
would look to see that we've got a
secured and protected area in terms of
ecology and habitats so just to show you
the plan imbalance because we have
pedestrian cycle routes into war pit we
have housing that is classified as being
sustainable as per the MPP F the walpert
neighbourhood plan is in its early
stages so limited way can only be given
to that local green space that they have
designated I believe that that is policy
you t12 WP t12 sorry the proposed site
access is within a transitional section
leading out of Woolpit the access will
have limited impact on this transitional
section with new planting being
introduced and highways are satisfied
with all the improvements sufficient to
accommodate the intensification of five
new dwellings thank you almost done
apologies ecology are obviously
satisfied with all the compensation
scheme and there are they believe that
this is adequate to mitigate the loss of
the important hedgerow at the front the
section 106 is to be agreed should this
be approved today and some conditions
titles there that were missed off the
report because over the Christmas period
we haven't quite had to play services
final comments done at the point of
writing the report that you have before
you so we've got the ecology appraised
and recommendations so everything that
in their survey that requests the the
recommendations of mitigation shall be
conditioned that they have to carry out
prior to the commencement some further
reptile survey and mitigation strategies
should be done carried out on the site
ecologies are satisfied with what
they've provided so far that there is
unlikely to be any harm towards any
protected species there is no evidence
of protected species within the site and
then as part of the reserve matters that
you would see come forward after this
outline application should it be
approved would require landscape and
ecology management plan like I
highlighted a second ago and also a
wildlife sensitive lighting design
scheme to go with the plan so
accordingly there is no sufficient harm
that would demonstrate there outweigh
the benefits of the highway improvements
on drink stone Road and with the five
new sustainable dwellings that would
outweigh the harm that has been
identified in terms of the loss of the
hedge fund so the recommendation is to
approve subject to the section 106 and I
will just put your attention to on page
one to four part of the recommendation
because of the neighbourhood plan going
through an examination stage on the 7th
of February and
just read this verbatim in the event
that the application has not been
determined by the time that the section
106 has been agreed and the neighborhood
plan examiner's report has been
published and B that report recommends
that that particular Wolpe local green
space policy is taken fully into account
that the designation application
sorry designation and allocation of the
application site as green space as
proposed within the draft neighborhood
plan then the application will be come
back to committee to have regard to the
material difference in policy change
thank you thank you very much I'm just
gonna just run through that last points
I think it's quite critical point so
what we're saying is that because the
neighbourhood plan is out for
examination throw it out for
consultation and the report is then
published we could have a conflict could
we based on today because it's only a
consultation period the neighbourhood
plan has very limited weight in our
decision-making that said if you approve
today we have to go away and secure the
section 106 now some solicitors can get
that done pretty quickly
some solicitors can take a while to get
that sorted at the point that that is
sorted should that neighbourhood plan
have gained more weight and an
examination report has been published
Part A and within that published report
that policy that asks for this
particular site to be local green space
or B ativ never be public it's private
land it's hedge Road all the way around
you can't access the site public
wouldn't be able to go and walk their
dog within it as such should both of
those come forward then we would say we
will bring it back to you as committee
because there is a material difference
in policy that is different today so
based on today that has very little
weight to it so I guess the question is
the application well I can I can guess
my own answer probably but the reason
the applications before stabilized would
have timed out so the application needs
to come forward rather than just waiting
for that to
decision which is due in a few weeks it
would be unreasonable it be unreasonable
for us to wait for that decision okay
thank you sir questions yes cancer
having him thank you I'm very unfair
report thanks Jamie I'm just a couple of
questions
the houses down the end of them ranks
Lane that you're showing on slide 13 the
sort of the ones with it sort of densive
you know it looks like a bit a bit the
far end of them ranks Lane are they'd
access to my explain or is that slight
thirteen those ones
do they come off ranks lane or Road so I
think he Rob there's no road access for
them on regs Lane there my understanding
is this broom Hill Lane I believe no so
they come on from this they don't come
on for exchanging so they come off right
what the question is do they come off
rags Lane um could you just quickly show
where from drinks down Lane how you get
in and out for pit as a how does it
relate to the village stench and pinch
points and all the rest of it yeah thank
you
so you can travel along during stone
rows and then there's a junction T
Junction here left into wall pit lane
for belief there is a pinch point within
that area that's been a part of many
other applications discussions that have
gone through I understand that there was
a previous application for a lot lot
more houses that it was discussed at a
length I'll let John update anyone on
that process but I know that those but
could you show the route to like that at
the April teens domain
yeah we just go to that first slide
that's the wider one so I believe that's
the a14 there so if you come down rags
lane you would come to the t-junction at
the end into the Wolcott Center and you
can go past the church and I believe you
go out this way from memory yeah and
then there's the turning point that
comes off the a14 there we wrap around
to a roundabout this here that goes off
into M as well and then back onto the
a14 that way yes but highways are
satisfied that we're only looking at
five houses that that's not an
intensification that would warrant a
refusal in this instance I understand
that the Business Park is up this end
there's bus routes into Mohsen Edmonds
there's also bus routes into Stowe
market I don't believe there's direct
bus routes into it's which I believe
you'd have to either go to first and for
that we're into Stowe market and on
obviously Stowe market has the train
station that goes straight into question
any other questions at this point
hmm yeah cancer Mayor Dan Council will
oh sorry can we have a little bit more
why is it unreasonable and not to delay
this hearing until after that maple
power the applications ready today to be
determined and we can't just hold off to
wait to hear until another policy might
come forward if the application is ready
we need to be deciding it as part of the
MPP F to be blunt I mean correct me if
I'm wrong in this instance if they've
been extensions granted by the applicant
or the applicant could appeal against
non determination is that right well
we'll have a go house ultimately thus
far we've been negotiating with the
applicant in order
to look at various issues which have
been explained by the case officer and
at this point we've got no further need
to look at negotiations because we've
got the development into a position
where we can take it forward if we were
to not take it forward and we would be
acting unreasonably in respect to
purposely delaying an application to
manipulate the situation so that a
policy that may or may not be adopted we
don't know what's going to happen at the
examination stage it may get amended at
that point it may get chucked out you
know it may not include this site it may
include other sites there are lots of
variables there and we are being
unreasonable then to delay it purposely
to see what that situation turns out we
would be as a council liable to appeal
as mentioned but of course that appeal
would also open us up to costs because
we are being unreasonable in our actions
in that context I appreciate we are in
limbo on a number of policy issues but
this is the position we are in at this
moment in time Thank You chair my
question is about the meadow who is
going to own the meadow in the future is
that to be transferred to a management
company to the parish council how how
can that be that wasn't intended that
should be secured and managed thank you
and the land is all within the
applicants ownership that whole meadow
I'd like to be able to get the ecology
compensation lay out in front of me cuz
it would be far better and more
appropriate to look at it if during this
conversation with me as I flick through
there we go so the applicant is in
ownership of all of this land here and
you go down the mouse has gone off the
screen there so it comes all the way
around that hole in Philly if you like
and my understanding is is that the
section 106 and the conditions that we
would ask in terms of the maintenance is
up to the applicant to maintain it as
per those conditions and nurses the
purpose of section 106 that is agreed
and
if counselors today feel as part of the
debate perhaps that that is a not enough
compensation even though our colleges
have said there's nothing to say that we
can't go back to the absolute have
further conversations about getting more
area to compensate the rest of the site
whether that then becomes actually an
open space for public's to walk their
dog I don't know if if you feel that
that is not enough compensation and
that's a conversation that perhaps we
could have further at this stage though
this is what we're bringing forward that
we feel as our professional judgment is
acceptable to allow for the development
to take place my my concern was a bit
more to do with who will own it who will
pay for the maintenance of it and if
there is a need for a changed
maintenance regime who who would who
would carry that out at the moment is
the applicant the applicant is the owner
it's up to them to maintain that land
that would be what is agreed with in the
condition and the ecologist is
recommended that that condition goes
forward that they would need to present
at reserve matters what the maintenance
scheme is and we would secure that under
the legal agreement as well it just add
to that so you're not in correct but um
I think I'm sensing where the council
was going here
ultimately this is not a piece of public
space where you would have an
expectation perhaps that the housing
approved would enter into a private
management company make some sort of
contribution and then maintain that area
and the reason it wouldn't probably work
commercially or anything else that
you're you wouldn't be able to do that
in this case because the people
occupying these houses get no benefit
out of maintaining a bit of land that
they never allowed to access or enter so
it's unlikely that a private management
company would be a way that the
applicant would deal with that
maintenance issue they mind to be able
to do that but that's not an issue for
us that's a commercial decision
ultimately the applicant in this case
has said that they are capable of
maintaining this land in accordance with
the condition and one of six that we lay
out the land at this moment in time is
being maintained to a certain degree
already where what we're talking about
here is maintaining and setting this
aside
as it is and gently maintained for the
purposes of ecology which I think in
cost terms is probably a lot less than
if it was a public site and therefore
probably within the means of the
applicant and any profit that they may
make out this development to maintain
for the foreseeable future again at this
moment in time of a planning point of
view we're satisfied that we've got a
condition and 106 regime that we can
enforce and maintain we don't entirely
know that means that how the applicant
will do that but we do have the means to
enforce it if necessary thank you keep
going down the line castor field yes
there was some question somewhere that
about the practicality of the
enhancements to drink standard Road the
formalization of asking Liza's
suggestion that Lang's not within the
applicants ownership and wondered what
the hard ways are confident that they
can achieve those changes and similar
theme on slide five they're sort of an
old area enclosed in red lines at the at
the end of the development on dreams
down the road I really don't understand
what it is I wonder if someone could
explain it to me
we should really be securing these
redlined more often these denote where
the visibility's plays are in essence
highways need to make sure that as
you're aware visibilities plays need to
be clear so people can see along there
if it sits outside of the redline plan
then it's not within our control to make
sure that that stays clear we can
condition to save visibilities plays
need to be made sure they're 0.6 meters
what the normal height setting is it's
important that we make sure we get those
within the redline plan so we can
guarantee it and conditions should only
be for things inside the redline plan in
section 106 should be outside of the
redline plan and normally within the
Blooey plan redline plan they're so blue
outline plan so yeah those redline plans
at the front there denote what the
visibility splays are and I've asked for
those to be included to make sure that
we can secure it but the little area
which is an enclosed type it drawing
triangle yeah so the roads what is that
I'm not quite Suman on these can i and I
think I've got eyes front yeah I have
got a zoomed in one have a knife
that side yet so if you can imagine
drink Stone Road would normally come
along here and can't get the mouse cut
go straight so the visibility splay is
taken from 2.4 meters back and then the
dotted line comes up to this point here
so everything beyond to the north of
that but you can see it goes all the way
to there so that's capturing what needs
to be so there is a section of that
meadow that comes out not quite so
you're just over lapping the road so
that's capturing that area there in
terms of what we need to secure is the
visibility space I don't know if these
flies were straight lines and yes
clearly god-king so the visibility
display there is that dotted line that's
where it's taken from 2.4 meters back
the red line is including any area
that's within that visibility display
because the visibly displays everything
to the north of that if you like because
if you're parked there you need to be
able to see everything along there so
that's area that we need to make sure is
clear and at the moment it isn't so it
basically that area in shaded in that
odd-shaped area has been taken out to
create a better visibility yes or added
into the edge development plan yeah
and the issue are the enhancements to
the pass in places achievable so I think
John will come back and the visibility
space we want to do that now and I'll
come back on terms no I was only gonna
convert don't know forgive you things
now actually couldn't you resolve that
point but I was just gonna say
ultimately anything within the red line
and in the visibility display is
declared as the ownership of the site
and ultimately if it turns out not to be
the case then there well that's their
issue they're gonna have to resolve
because we've got a condition that says
that's how it shall be so ultimately
what we have in front of us is what we
feel is going to be achieved it's not
able to be achieved by the applicant if
there's any other ownership issues
they're gonna have to come back and
resolve those with us if it's resolvable
at all and that is their risk
okay just yeah and in terms of the
improvements of the the highways yes
Suffolk highways have dealt with this
from the pre apt stage and Sam in
Suffolk County Council highways was
happy that we could do this this is
normally done by T ro and we can do this
section 106 or now to make sure that it
comes forward as part of the development
so this the the improvements on highways
land so we don't need to serve notice to
anyone so we satisfied that we can bring
those forward one last point perhaps the
width of the road at that point where
the red dot is there where your cursor
is at the moment it's quoted as five
point five metres both side of it that
looks a heck of a lot less
Pinker says 4.50 just doctor going just
say this is a Louisville Road and
ultimately it does have variations of
width along it so I don't want to be
caught quoting all of the limp for the
road is five meters when it's not
because there are variations and of
course on there there's a variation of
five and it goes down to four point five
and then goes out to five again it has
you know not a consistent with all the
way along it I don't know if you want to
add anything more to that well I just
clarified what those annotations
actually say so that is annotating the
visibility splay being two point four
meters back which is taken from that
part by eighty five meters so it's going
from there to there eighty five meters
so that's what that annotation says this
annotation actually says the
formalization of the existing passing
Bay to make it five point five meters
across
including the passing Bay that one just
devotes what we've already talked about
about the hatched area denoting the
existing the extensor II visibility
space and then this one here says
carriageway width to be tapered down
from six let me make sure all that
different ears five point five three in
twenty meters in length so from there
five point five starting and then it's
tapering down and then on this side
we've got the new access which is going
to be done for as per the standard
Suffolk County Council drawing which is
dm0 one which is public drawing there's
a specification of what an access should
be and then we can go back that there's
no there's no four point five on there
there's five point five the next one
that one is two point four meters so
next one there is
ah in the middle there yes so that's
that's taking it from there Paula jeez I
was reading the annotations laboratory
sorry yeah so that one's definitely for
4.5 is a measurement there there's two
five five yes and then I think if we
flip back there is that one as well do
you want me to go through those
annotations as well happily do safe
beeping okay we're still going along
counselor mode Thank You chair yeah and
thanks for the presentation that was
pretty clear and a couple questions one
is you you showed a double gate way
further along drinks in road which is
going to be stopped up and a new one
opened any idea where the position of
that will be and does it require it so
invisibility supply so the new one is
the main access that we've been talking
about we that the old one I believe is
about here I think the reason that the
applicant and perhaps this is a question
we can ask off of them when they come to
the end if they are come to the stand
about why they're not utilizing this
access to ask for the development to
prevent us putting a new one in my guess
would be so we don't have development
slap-bang in the middle of that meadow
we actually have it to one side closer
to where the development line of regs
Lane is allowing for that to remain as a
whole so given that we now got an
indicative red line showing a new edge
coming in how will the applicant access
the site to do the maintenance and so
forth on the new planting I think the
turning head was always going to be
their option to do such a thing it might
be a case that we're going to retain
retain that access there I think the new
ecology plan that we had as the
compensation scheme with the hedgerow
going through that is maybe something
that's been overlooked in terms of how
they now access that site as a whole
because that is something that came in
over a consultation period with ecology
over the Christmas period so it might be
a case of if we can find it there so I
think the turning head was always going
to allow that for access it might be now
that they retain that that access there
to be able to access the rest of their
motto if they do or do not stop that
hard
doesn't change what we're proposing here
is a recommendation and it's not
something that we would ask them to
secure as part of section 106 to stock
that up if it stays as an access to the
meadow we don't have any problems with
that okay just a further question on
that on the biodiversity so I mean in
the papers we have from play services a
holding objection dated the fourth of
November you saying that that's being
removed now and we have their approval
yeah that's correct at the time that
this report was written we had their
comments come back to us on the 6th of
January
apologies I should have brought that
perhaps as a late paper but if we go
back onto the slides please I have
included they've basically lifted
they're going the wrong way these areas
like around they've lifted they're
holding objection and they have asked
for the four conditions and I've just
put the titles in there for ease at the
moment but we've got action required in
accordance with the ecology appraisal
recommendations so in essence what they
have submitted is their survey has a
whole chapter believers chapter six off
the top of my head which asks it's their
recommendations and mitigations that's a
very common condition that we would put
onto approvals that essentially just
says you have to do it as per what your
mitigation and recommendations are
within your survey the prior to
commencement reptile survey mitigation
strategy Hamish was quite clear in his
response and six that that is happy to
be conditioned in s in examples where we
think that it is likely that there is
going to be some kind of reptile
movements within there we wouldn't do
that prior to the determination Hamish
is happy in this scenario that is
unlikely that would be the case so we
would still ask for the surveys to be
done but we're happy because it's a low
risk to do it thereafter the other one
is the landscape and ecology management
plan which we've discussed here they
would have to bring that forward as part
of the reserve matters and the sensitive
lighting and design scheme so these have
come as part of him it's at the time of
writing this report I'd spoken to Hamish
he said he's going to
lift the holding objection but it will
give it to me in writing so I was able
to get on with the report over the
Christmas period and get that done and
then his comments come in so I've just
added those in there Thank You yep
keep going on the line Cass so anyone
else
Katsura Ellen yep we'll come we'll come
back to the board members at the end
this is this is just a very quick
question is Alan to do with the
pre-application advice it was given in
respect of DC 1901 six nine six was that
an application for similar application
was it four five houses or was that for
a larger application please it was four
five I'm not sure whether or not the pre
app itself was titled to be five that
was what part of the pre app discussions
were what is the intensification limit
that would be acceptable from a highways
point of view and after many maximum
four words throughout that pre
application process which I person
wasn't involved in and but that was what
was seen is 5 being the acceptable
number but it was for this not the whole
meadow that's a bigger part of the
measure I think as part of the pre-op
they may have brought forward the site
and said here's the site what was
acceptable we've had 60 refused we've
had 45 refused what is acceptable and 5
was what was determined so anything that
came forward thereafter would have to
see some significant highways
improvements to allow any increase in
number but obviously that's not what's
before us today
so was oh one six nine six did was that
brought to committee was that refused
was it withdrawn so
it's on page 1 1 1 of your report it
says as the application being subject to
Priya advice yes DC 1901 63 up wouldn't
come forward a committee the pre-op I
don't know what did did that particular
application this is this is the
application so we're okay thanks I still
don't quite understand because this
seems to be a different review but just
to clarify the history obviously we've
had a previous application on the site
that was refused was which was for far
more houses and that was for the whole
of the land there
we have had three application
discussions since then as a planning
department now we reference all of our
free application discussions and we give
them a specific reference number this is
the same reference regime as we give a
planning application so apologize for
the confusion in that respect
yeah anyone else yeah so can I just
confirm that this site is not included
in either extensions to the settlement
boundary or by means of an allocation in
the local plan correct
any other questions now would members
you had a question
yeah yeah if we can go back to I think
it's slide 5 which I presume is a scale
drawing I'm just like to clarify that
this application just asked I mean this
cleric this applications outline with
access and layout secured now the
proposed footpath and cycle access to
rags lane looks narrow I thought that
footpath cycleways needed to be 3 meters
and given that the width of the road and
where the little triangle bit we've just
been talking about is 4.5 meters that
path does not look like 3 meters so can
you please clarify if a footpath
cycleway link should be 3 meters
but while they are checking that again
SEC were involved in that whole process
in terms of the Highways Authority and
they gave no objection in terms of a
width of that or asked for that to be
wider or we didn't have any indication
from them that that should be secured
well I've got a separate question but
I've got a little bit of information on
that on on counsel amount source so I
could add that or I could just go into
my question okay we look at page 156 and
slightly slide 5 would also be useful
there I think paragraph 3 point 2 it
says that the southern edge that's the
hedge laundry extra note it will merely
need to be finished from the visibility
displays it will be retained as much as
possible perhaps only 15 meters will
need to be fully removed for the new
entrance now we don't seem to have a
drawing that shows the loss of only 15
meters of hedge but if you scale off the
slide 5 and that's on page 162 you'll
you'll I appreciate that you don't have
scaled rulers with you here but I did do
this and you'll quickly see that 15
meters is just the width of the asphalt
splay where it's questions yes and so
that means the retained hedge from the
ecological mitigation of what would run
right up to the curb of the new access
road and it's hard to see how that would
work now I am coming to my question even
even where the hedge I was just trying
to give you the context of this which
one is correct that's the loss of 15
meters of hedge or the loss as we're
saying even where the hedge seems to be
shown is retained there's that time the
losses of over 100 meters perhaps I'm
not explaining this very clearly but if
you see if you see it on on that slide
you can see that this play is going for
over a hundred meters 15 meters is only
the width of the asphalt display the
tarmac space so we my question is which
one is right and the more substantial
question is which one has been agreed by
highways the loss of the hedge for 15
meters or the loss of the edge for a
hundred meters it you'll see that these
are very large discrepancies and on page
120 it says the southern boundary will
be lost which rather makes a nonsense of
the new mitigation strategy so which one
has been agreed the ecology report from
my understanding is saying where
possible to retain some this is
planning essentially we we have highways
where highways conflicts ecology and
colleges you can flick that and we have
to find that balance highways worries
going to say they want to whatever needs
to be lost will need to be lost for the
visibility's plays so my understanding
is I'm speaking to Hamish is that's what
the report has done from geo has seen
that as if it can't be this is what the
compensation is to reflect that so we
anticipate that the vast majority where
that pink area is alive well it's on the
page 162 which is the compensation one
and I will flick forward it is the other
end of the presentation to go back
forward but we have had that slide on
there which shows the blue area of what
would be the meadow and at the front is
some pink squares pink rectangle sorry
of what will be the area where new
planting will need to be provided so in
answer to your question I think the
easiest way to say is even if it was all
lost we understand from Hamish our play
services and the geo survey here that
the compensation given mitigates even if
it was all lost within that period it
won't be all lost across the whole site
because it will be vastly much retained
from there to there so if we lost it
from there so there the compensation
scheme that we have been given we have
satisfied through our consultation the
bat mitigation we're just saying that
the 0.25 Hector's of meadow creation is
that's the compensation as part of the
compensation of the loss yes this
compensation has been done against and
and I have to admit I'm not greatly
detailed in terms of how it exactly
works this is why we use Play Services
compensation as sorry as console tease
but Defra have a table of mitigation and
that gives units to each individual area
of what is an addition and what is being
removed so for example and I hope this
is correct that they might say that that
hedgerow is worth 100 units in total and
we are then being given x y&z that make
up that I will just add that I have
forgotten to mention each house and it
is on that page 162 if you have it
each house has bat and bird boxes on
each house one on each side so we've got
bat and bird bat and bird so that also
adds up to the compensation do you have
any other questions mr. board members
[Applause]
okay yeah do some the design of the
3-meter cycle John it's one of those
questions that I should know the answer
to and when you go to look it up you
can't find it um there is nothing in the
manual for streets that I can find
although saying that the document it's
got 146 pages so bear with me a bit
longer and I'll keep looking
there's nothing in the car parking most
recent guys because that talked about
car parking and certain standards
nothing in the Suffolk design guide per
se its which Borough Council have
adopted it as a sonic all statutory so
they vividly said it has to be three
meters as a minimum I'm just trying to
work out where they go that form I
presume that's come somewhere from the
Suffolk okay but in terms of this
council and what it has adopted as
policy we have actually adopted any of
those but ultimately as guidance I'm
still looking so it's it sounds very
familiar because that's the one I pretty
much had in my head three meters being
for a two-way sonic all shared position
at one way as two meters in a two way as
three meters
I'm just having to go back through my
head to work out where I got that form
in the first place to keep bear with me
a little bit longer I look at debate
going I'll try and find that okay
any other questions on the presentation
at the stage from anyone nope okay so
we're going to move on so we move
forward now to the speakers who'd like
to come up and for the three minutes
first of all we have from the parish
council Judi Evans
un's I'm sorry
if you like no it's my pronunciation I
do apologize and you have three minutes
from when you start thank you
Alma thank you
this site is not suitable for housing
development for many reasons the access
roads are narrow and without footpaths
the applicants proposal to alleviate
this issue is confused and probably
undeliverable mr. Currie a local
resident will speak about traffic and
pedestrian routers in more detail the
Parish Council agrees with what he will
say and from our local knowledge we can
confirm that the village agrees with him
also the site lies outside the village
settlement boundary there is no proposal
to change this in the draft local plan
or in the neighbourhood plan and I was
very pleased to hear that you all now
acknowledge that the statements in the
papers which say that the neighbourhood
plan is in the early stages are
incorrect we are nearly there with our
neighbourhood plan and it is very
unlikely we feel to change so far as
this site is concerned where it is
designated as green space with several
large sites around the village already
granted permission there is no need for
housing here the environmental harm is
not outweighed by five large houses the
proposed road layout invites the
conclusion that further applications for
this site can be expected this site
fulfills a vital role is a true wildlife
habitat close to the village centre now
the district council officers have
clearly been having discussions about
ecology recently that perhaps the Parish
Council has not been privy to but we
feel that the environmental harm is not
outweighed by five new large houses the
proposed road layout inverts the
conclusion that as I believe councillor
geek just said that the the the the
ancient hedge line
we'll be virtually destroyed for a good
half of its length not the 15 meters
that I believe is referred to in the
papers a site contains a mixture of
trees shrubs and ancient hedges and
rough grass it may look a bit scruffy
but that is exactly how nature likes it
wildlife identified on site by by local
parishioners include jays green
woodpeckers spotted woodpeckers Kestrel
sparrow hawk owls Warblers and yellow
hammers which I'm told her on the red
endangered list
frogs grass snakes monk Jack and roe
deer it's well known you can't dig a
small hole anywhere in a war pit without
a newt finding a home in it fairly
quickly the promise of a manufactured
measure meadow which we notice outside
the application site and a feud burdened
batbox
afraid you have hit the three minutes so
happy the final sentence please I'm
sorry the parish councillors of walpert
urge rejection of the proposal without
my glasses I can't see your egg timer
sorry no problem sir thank you very much
do you have any questions for the Parish
Council at this point no okay thank you
very much thank you
next up we have Derek curry as an
objector again if you'd like to come up
and you have three minutes as well
please
yes deric curry I've lived in Wolcott 45
years 37 of them opposite the proposed
site the site is not appropriate for
development because of the destruction
of the wildlife habitat as previously
and the medieval hedgerow and the
inadequate local roads to cope with
pedestrians and traffic so all these are
important but I want to focus on the
pedestrians and the traffic all traffic
including delivery vehicles etc would
access the site via drinks and Road
formerly called plow lane by the way the
passing place that's been noted is
actually a field entrance pedestrians
will leave this site via the vehicular
access because that is the most direct
route to the school and the health
center there's no pavement in drinks and
Road and pedestrians would also have to
cross green road at the infamous pinch
point before they reach a pavement at
all all traffic from this site will have
to enter the frequently gridlock center
of Woolpit in order to reach a 14-2
travel in either direction in the centre
lorries unload and buses try to get
through parked vehicles farm equipment
also travels through and I often hope no
emergency vehicles are required because
the village centre is frequently
impassable now and the situation will
also get worse when the hundred plus
vehicles from the previously approved
Green Road site which is being developed
now come into play some drivers from the
new proposed estate will try to avoid
the pinch point by turning right to
enter the village via broom Hill Lane
and rags lane the width of rags Lane is
often about 3.6 meters cars can pass
each other but only if they go up
lives are up our from banks mitre closed
has 40 houses rags I in 17 and the
bottom of broom Hill Lane 4 there's a
hundred plus cars already plus cyclists
using rags lane as part of national
cycle route 51
there are mobility scooters and existing
mums with children in buggies etc and
now more local pedestrians are proposed
large event vehicles including oil
tankers block track sign to unload these
have to enter from Broome Hill Lane
because there's no room to turn in or
out at the village centre do depart
vehicles and the two listed buildings at
the narrow entrance huge lorries
including refuse collection lorries
often have to reverse the whole length
of rags Lane
many of the several hundred workers at
Woolpit Business Park use the local
lanes family crazy to have fun over the
three minutes if I could have the last
sentence please thank you
during their lunch breaks and groups of
them are seen in rags lane and broom
Hill Lane daily there is no footpaths
thank you very much
do you have any questions thank you very
much thank you thank you now we don't
have a supporter and we don't have the
applicant or agents I understand here to
speak nope
okay so we go straight on yeah and we're
going to answer the question that was
asked you asked earlier and then we'll
come onto the ward members
[Music]
okay so I've gone through that document
and I can't find a Pacific mention of
three meters as a minimum requirement I
there was only one mention of cycle path
in terms of a where you have pedestrian
and cycle using the same and where there
is the ability to split the path it
recommends three point three meters but
I'd also just would like to point out
the response from the Highways Authority
as well on this issue if you turn to
page 143 you'll see that there is a
specific mention of footpath link into
vex Lane
being two meters by two so that
therefore that would indicate that the
path would be two meters wide there's
two meters by 2 meters so that indicates
that the path itself will need to be 2
meters wide if that helps okay so as I
said we've gone to the ward members
council Helen Keaton councillor
Sarah Mansur / - who wants to go first
your call thank you firstly I should say
that I agree with everything that mr.
Zients and mr. Carey have said last time
this site came before committee it was
rejected for several reasons social on
page 134 all of which are still
pertinent first of all the lack of
pedestrian connectivity made it
unsustainable not outweighed by
providing 45 houses so presumably even
less outweighed by the benefit of only
providing 5 secondly there was
unacceptable highway safety in both rain
and drink stern road again not
outweighed by 45 houses but if Frank's
lane wasn't safe for the inhabitants of
45 houses to walk along then why is it
safe for those in five houses to walk
along now particularly as Mr curry said
when we have an increased number of
pedestrians walking to the village from
the expanded business park
finally there was inadequate provision
for infrastructure notably affordable
housing again this development is
similar this disagreement as far as I
can see between officers about this page
123 says that affordable housing the
contribution isn't required but
strategic housing on page 151 says it is
required and clearly the site's being
configured to try to avoid affordable
housing as from the officer's report
excellent stuff about the hitches we're
most concerned about h1 that ancient
hedge border in Kingston Road tall
diverse south-facing almost certainly
medieval in origin in general those
lanes with their hedges are among the
oldest features in the landscape and
this one drink Stern Road can be found
on the manorial extent for 1567 which is
the earliest documentary source we have
for Woolpit
so it is likely to be medieval you can't
replace this with modern planting you
can't create a fresh the balance that we
have at the moment including those
invisible assets like tiny invertebrates
and fungi and so on
at the moment we are in a biodiversity
crisis so we should not risk losing that
habitat it supports countless
invertebrates and pollinators now just
as you can't replace an ancient hedge
you can't create a quarter hectare of
meadow to compensate for the loss of
half of that green space this this used
to be wool pits allotments that latent
fertility that nutrient-rich soil makes
it very challenging to establish a grass
and flower meadow it will involve
tearing up literally everything that's
there at the moment as you'll have seen
in the ecological mitigation report it
is not maintenance support is there now
at present it is not a stable grassland
meadow
it's on its way to secondary woodland if
even if eventually that meadow becomes a
food source of insects it wouldn't have
the complexity of what's already been
there now moving on to highway so you've
spent a while looking at drinks turn
road a good while looking at drinks to
know what isn't mentioned in the papers
is that pinch point the the vehicular
access along drinks - no - the a14 now
that the green road development you'll
know the one was refused in 2016 on
highways grounds and an appeal was
allowed with the condition that a
detailed scheme for highway improvements
to Green Road was agreed this has never
been agreed although construction has
already begun on Green Road I don't want
to get into this in detail it's very
time-consuming but essentially we're
still awaiting a design to mitigate that
pinch point after I think the first
three designs have been rejected by
highways and surely the ranks lane site
should not be considered until the
schemes being agreed for that pinch
point and work has started on it now
finally it ought to be pointed out that
this is not just any overgrown field on
the edge of orbit the field was as I
said will pits allotments for nearly a
century as recently as the mid 1980s and
although the community has never
actually owned the land it is special to
us we know it as a place to see wildlife
to missus ewtn's list I could add the
barn owl that I saw the weekend before
last we go there to lean on the gate and
rest we go there to get a view of
wildness in nature that's that's rarely
seen in our busy community and we have a
sentimental attachment to that place
maybe it doesn't count in planning terms
but it does make it ideal for
designation as a local green space this
is essentially five more large houses in
an important wild green space on two
problematic roads near
to an unresolved traffic safety issue so
unsurprisingly I can tell you I didn't
support it very much should we do both
ward members and then we'll have to see
if you've got any questions just an
answer thank you I too would like to
agree with the comments already made by
the parish counts or the resident and my
fellow board member about the
environmental and highways impacts of
this particular development but I would
like to comment on the subjectivity of
how much weight this committee are going
to put on various policies that we have
the emerging wall pit neighborhood plan
which has already been spoken about we
also have our own emerging joint local
plan we have a load of policies in our
current local plan which our planning
officers tell us are out of date and
therefore we can't put much weight on
them we have the NPP F we also have the
refusal notice for the 45 houses on the
larger site that was zero zero seven to
one
we also may want to look at the
cumulative impact of other large
developments in ball pit and I think it
is subjective we've heard the officers
view on how much weight should be given
to those things but it's your decision
as a committee to determine how much
weight you are going to put on them so
the site is outside the existing
settlement boundary the proposed
settlement boundary and I'll draft joint
Local Plan and in the emerging war pit
neighborhood plan so effectively that is
development in the countryside and it
still is a wolf pit neighborhood plan
policy WPT 12 this this is a local green
space I know with the MPs at an early
stage but it has a limited amount of
weight if not conservative you know it's
okay it's not considerable amount of
weight we're told by our planning
officers that we have to discount our
own policies cs1 and cs2 because they're
out of date so we then therefore are
relying on NPP F paragraph 8 which is
now all about sustainable development
we're told there are three strands of
sustainability economic sustainability
okay we're going to get some temporary
benefits during the construction phase
but we can't count that really as
economic benefit the social benefit what
significance will put it all ready got a
load of housing and it's likely to have
about six hundred plus new homes so five
more what's the difference between six
hundred and five and six hundred homes
to an already thriving community the
environmental sustainability we've been
told about the mitigation proposed now
when I read the report we weren't sure
what the final detail was and we're now
told that the place services have agreed
that the mitigation is sufficient but
again I think that's a little bit
subjective does will pretty need five
more large houses not really I think
there's probably more need for smaller
properties and affordable homes neither
of which are going to be in this
development now my fellow board members
already mentioned that the reasons for
refusal for 0:07 to 140 the burnt dish
you know the the environmental harm it's
not was not outweighed by the benefits
of 45 new dwellings so I really can't
see how it can be outweighed by five and
we've had lots of talk about the
unacceptable highway safety I am a
little concerned about the two meter
cycle way every other time I've asked
about cycle ways I'm told there's not
enough room because we need three meters
and here we are we're cramming a cycle
way between the wall of a of a garage
and a hedge and it's only two meters I
really think that we should be asking
for a slightly you know if this is going
to be approved two meters isn't wide
enough thank you thank you very much
question to all this council having so
I'm considering in the neighborhood plan
they put that space down for open space
of green space whatever they're calling
it because it's private properties there
anything to stop the guy blaring it up
and coppicing the hedges down to this
side
exactly this is formal allotments but
essentially it's defined in planning
terms as therefore cultural and so we
could plant the whole site for crops
tomorrow
there'd be not a lot we can do about
that that is have a call to land okay so
members questions for Ward members at
this point yeah can Sophia
sorry I just caught the tail end of that
question no I understood hedges are
protected in agricultural environments
and you're simply not allowed to you can
cop I think the point is they could be
coppiced
I think cancer having having a farmer
would you know it's coppice I think I
think the point is it's a it's private
land that's really my point is you can't
rip okay so any other questions for the
wards the two board members at this
point no yeah castle willow just one
very quick question is there a different
way to get to the a14 from the ranks
Langston Road area that if you were
going to bury some Edmonds could you get
out a different way and and is that is
that used as a rat run when the the
village sentries can Jess don't
yeah yes yes you you can in theory avoid
pinch point by not turning left turning
right and going away from wall pit and
turning into Greenhill Lane which is an
incredibly narrow to use I hope it's too
technical a turn a hole in a hollow way
it's it's you can't ease off sorry son
can Lane thank you and is currently
causing problems at every parish council
meeting because there are lorries going
up and down it's eroding the the earth
part which is then leading to drains
blocking so people do go up and down
there but again it's full of pedestrians
it's a it's a very unusual and
interesting Lane and it's not one that
we should
it's the one that the Business Park is
is close to and it's recently had
restrictions placed on it and there's
discussions around other restrictions to
try to stop people using it thank you
any other questions okay members we've
had all the information put before us
we've heard from the parish council
we've hid from a resident and objector
we haven't heard from the support of the
applicant obviously we've heard from the
two board members and we've had the case
presented to us so every us discussed
debate and to reach a conclusion between
us somehow yes Kassem Ellis straighter
and thank you chair so I have a real
concern about what I what appears to be
a discrepancy in the environmental
report by Geo and I'm looking at the
plan on page 160 which shows the sort of
improved environmental mitigation
measures and is a small print but I
think it says existing hedging and trees
with invisibility splays to be removed
and I think this goes back to the point
that counselor keep made earlier and if
you turn over to the table on page 169
with the this of biodiversity metric
calculation grid it's a bit of a
struggle for those of us are not
familiar with these things but it
appears to be that the native species
rich hedgerow has to 259 meters of
length and that gets diminished to 244
so that's the 15 meters we talked about
so there's clearly a discrepancy between
what it says on the plan which is a much
longer area of of ancient species rich
mature hedgerow to be ripped out and the
amount they've actually used in their
calculations and I struggle to see that
place services have done a a correct job
in their calculation of the sort of net
benefit of the
hunting's and so forth so that leads me
to to be heading in a direction of being
against this development at this stage
of the debate I think and I think we've
gotta be careful let's cause John do you
want to just come in on that point I
hope you look at this again but it
depends on what is defined as the
protective edge in terms of the
protected species I'm not sure if those
two calculations add up because not all
of the hedge is regarded as protected
but I'm not sure because I'm not I'm not
an expert in that regard so I'm I'm I'm
guest working here why there's a
difference but ultimately for the
purposes of planning the extent of
hedgerow is clear on the plan and the
plan would be the one I would take
forward if you consider that to be
inappropriate and the mitigation that's
also on the same plan that would be a
debate that you would need to consider
that that on page 169 and I'm terribly
sorry I didn't pick this up before the
figures which presumably are in the
table it then says on the right hand
side site land dad's Hill Lane west of
Perth and Huntington close north alt
that isn't in wall pet as far as I'm
concerned are these figures actually the
correct figures
so basically well very well spotted
thank you pointed out that's very
important no so what we will have to do
is defer this bring it back next time
we'll need the Geo here just to confirm
whether this is act or a report from
turn the mic on it's up to you I'm
chairman and members unless we carry on
I noticed this is a bit messy unless we
carry on with some other business
attempt to get something by email or
phone from where I sit I think both the
board members have raised points about
the report that we're not a hundred
percent confident in and I think to just
get an email just confirming yay or nay
isn't I think we need that we need them
here or we need someone here to try and
talk it through from place services
would be my take okay thank you bear
with us so essentially given the
reference within the applicants details
that they've submitted to us appears to
refer to a different site now whether
that is a cut and paste error or or
anything else I would say that there is
sufficient risk that the are experts who
have looked at the information have
potentially not looked at the light
report or the right table on that basis
I would recommend to members that there
is a if we if you made a decision based
on that information and that potential
error you would be potentially open to a
judicial review risk and I would
therefore urge a consideration of
deferment on that basis we would not
feel comfortable so I think we need it's
deferred and we need to come back with a
greater clarity on that point yes
counselor having yeah is everyone in
favor of that can we have a show of
hands everyone a favor of deferment on
that basis ask unanimous thank you I do
apologize to members of the public not
to have had that but I think it's really
important that we get this right and we
don't make a decision on past
information that we're not hundreds
unsure
so we'll take a quick 10-minute break
and start again at quarter past twelve
you
welcome back everyone and again
apologies I don't like to pull something
but if it's not right we've got to do it
so moving straight on to agenda item 7c
and this is that lawn farm Warren Lane
Woolpit application I'm DC 1985 double-a
Thank You chair and good afternoon
members and everybody else got two
applications with us for this site and I
think I should explain the background to
it because that although they procedure
lead to applications they do inform each
other
members may recall granting permission
for business users at lawn farm in the
summer of 2018 at the time a condition
was imposed that committee which
referred to variously attend meter Bund
or buffer the wording was elusive
actually it was a buffer a planting
buffer of 10 meters in width at the time
the applicant did express a bit of
concern about it hampering matters on
site but did Julie discharge that
condition in order to begin works on
site what they're asking to down to this
application if that is is if that
condition could be varied which would
remove reference to the 10 meter buffer
so we'll talk about that first and the
second application then seeks to
increase employment use on the site with
three further parcels of land nearby so
let's go for the slides let's use the
writer piece of equipment
okay so there is that the site in
question hopefully you're familiar with
it you've got the a14 just to the left
to the to the west of lawn farm the the
shape of the site in question you can
see is it upside down L shape and to the
left and right are the parcels that
would be talking about next
but this application relates to the
shaded area only point of reference
it's obviously near major road networks
the a14 the old a 14 as well oh sorry
the old London roadster site as well and
to the bottom right corner you can see
just a few buildings there are three
dwellings nearby to what you listed okay
so in 2018 members grant a permission
for what you see before you now so the
buildings on the left were granted full
permission the top left one has been
built out members may have seen it it is
quite visible it's a mixture of white
and sky blue colors that's been built
out and it's being used the southern
building they're about to break ground
on that they just at the end of sorting
out the contract for that and as
reported on the table papers the site to
the right which has outline permission
is subject to a reserve masters
application which we've just received
and notifications will go out for that
short so just to talk you through it
that's being occupied that's about to be
started on that's about to be applied
for as well but what we also got coming
up our top left there parcel one
possible to and then over to the West
parcel three so the landowner wishes for
the business park to be built out and
that is how they hope it will end up
should they be granted permission I'm
just going to show you a view of lawn
farm as one would see it from the a14
that's the main viewpoint excuse me so
we're coming from the south here and
it's over on our right there over on the
east so it's screened in part but then
is open in parts as well I had to go
over the other side of the road
this because there was a Eddie Stobart
bar in the way but I'm still going on
the same way and then coming back going
South woods it's on our left now
did I say left earlier I meant right
sorry shall I go back have I confuse
anybody in that fight okay
so there it is basically is exposed on
the left and then you go down towards
the south it's planted out now I need to
point out a few things here is it with
this the planting in contention
basically is is is this here it's the
ten meter buffer referred to in places
Bund but forget the word but there's no
button sea goes up all the way the spine
of the development like that details of
this have been submitted and plant is
being begun but the problem is no the
problem is that this this section here
it would hamper access to these two
parcels here so the black dots you see
there are no longer planting they are a
lawn area but will have a public
right-of-way over it this is a public
right-of-way so that's kept as such so
there's not any planting there the
applicant is asking if that can be
removed
I say removed you know not not put into
stop and also this section here it can
be thinned to about six meters so that
will make it easier to operate within
these parcels of land the compensation
for that is actually a net gain in
specimens and that game in acreage off
planting which would be here where the
width of that is about 28 meters and
down here where the width is about 30
meters tapering down to as you can see
you
nothingjust just a point the bottom
there and also hedgerow planting here a
councillor key earlier speaking about a
lot of hedgerows so we can give you
hopefully don't use so its heads were
there but it can gave you a hundred and
fifty meters hedgerow here
okay so just to confirm that the
applicant was asking to reduce that
planted belt from ten to six meters it's
giving up to 35 meters depth here two
meter planting here and could be a bit
wider actually to be honest up to 28
meters depth here and that belt would be
lost so you could then open up access to
proposed sites one and two well it had
been begun I must admit I don't know how
far they got there I've got photos on
the other application which show some of
the planting hadn't been done I just
want to give you an aerial photograph as
well so you could say gasps pecked as it
is at the moment so we've got the stag
cafe there this is all wooded there's a
little bit of planting there but
basically the proposal is to to put a
belt a thick belt here and then the
thinner belt there and then not there at
all and then hedgerows along here and
also to mention other residential
dwellings which I mentioned earlier
which include lawn farm front cottage
and and the relevance of this is we've
just been successful at an appeal for
some housing in this site here the
applicant wanted housing where there are
business units at the moment scaffolding
company is operating and we resisted
because we feared there may be conflict
between a proposed use here and
increased residential here and the
inspector grievers
it was yes it's different Apple yeah
yeah okay so I think yes back to the
start so that that's the story there
really on this application the applicant
is asking very kindly if if the planting
belt which was agreed at last committee
could be altered with all that other
compensate replanting which I've shown
you so they can then proceed to the next
part of the story which is the next
application question - I you - you've
been very clear that where some of it's
not even planted yet some of its being
thinned and then there's new areas going
in and the amount of new area that's
going to be fun stuff is in excess of
what was previously offered what sort of
percentages in excess I haven't got
those figures but if you do a visual
comparison you'll see that I'll go back
a few slides can I you'll see that there
is there's quite a difference in terms
of what's been plotted what has an iron
must admit I don't know that information
perhaps the applicant else later off
that they certainly it's been worked on
okay so that is the first one so if you
look at where's difficult here okay so
apples and X is difficult to compare
exactly oh yes thank you other questions
yes let's start down this end first one
could you refresh my memory
why did we want the 10 meter bomb was it
a long ye or something what was the
purpose of putting it in that location
yeah I was at the meeting but I've
completely forgotten that potato-eater
my colleague Vincent Pierce covered the
committee wasn't there but I think the
fundaments of it were that there was a
wish to just try and disguise the
developments much as possible and what's
happened since then is I didn't mention
him a report is that the site has been
allocated as an employment land so the
the applicant has a desire to expand use
on the site and that that buffer would
hamper progress
now this is purely speculative and not
don't want this to be guaranteed but
councillor Barker was on the committee
at the time and I think he was quite
insistent being involved in this sort of
thing that he thought it would be
appropriate and talked about it to the
committee but I don't know if that we
can't be a hundred special that's from
memory minutes if you wanted the liquor
council Wellum Thank You chair so for
whatever reason ten metres was deemed
appropriate probably to shield the
visual impact of some buildings but not
necessarily it was I guess they could
also have been in order to provide
habitats in which whichever it might be
that was ten meters
why is two meters now being suggested as
adequate is there have you got some
reasoning why you think that would be
appropriate having reduced it by up to
20%
but having some plot different planting
in different places it's I mean saying
it's been ten there's even proposed by
two is an interpretation of it what's
actually happens it tends been replaced
by six for half the site and then there
isn't any at the north but in addition
to that it's the two meters or even more
if you want hedgerow on the on the
western part the site so yeah having not
have the advantage of being here
certainly wasn't part the applications
that there would be a green corridor
wildlife corridor for the site that
emerged during committee so I don't know
why that happened at the end of
committee but that wasn't certainly in
the mind of the applicant at the time
I've got the minutes of the last meeting
and it purely says councillor Leslie
mayor's proposed the application be
approved as detailed for the author's
recommendation with additional
conditions ten metres of landscape
buffer on the wall pit side five metre
boundary on the north frontage so I
suspect it was a decision discussed by
committee just decided to widen it it on
that section
Casa Phil sorry looking at slide seven
there's a dotted line which says public
right-of-way so I guess the ten meters
was to ensure the public right-of-way
was along a pleasant route
ultimately the decision made was the
dessert made and I'm trying to if I can
push members away from that a little bit
ultimately your consideration in respect
that this application is whether the
reconfigured landscaping arrangement is
satisfactory and does not cause harm or
concern in the terms of probably the
wider landscape issues there is a public
footpath along that site it leads I
believe to the a14 to cross over it so
I'm not convinced it would be the best
thing to encourage but ultimately it's
not something that the applicant can
remove because they don't have the
powers to do that it's one of those
things so they have essentially lined up
some of their landscaping against that
public footpath but whether that's just
a default because it's logical I don't
know I would say the other problem we
have here is the photographs we've got
we can't take photographs on the 8th
from the a14 without endangering our
lives or trying to hold a camera while
driving at the same time so a lot of
those photographs are from the Google
van the cameras they use if we actually
go on there today a lot of this building
is actually up I think you may notice it
given the coloring of the building and I
think you know in that sense we now have
a better idea of the top at the idea how
this impact of these buildings will be
in context with the surrounding areas
that we are now having to look at
against the landscaping that we've got
proposed before us and ultimately we've
weighed that in the balance and
and we're here before you today thank
you right
we're still on questions at this point
any other questions almost being
presented no okay so we're gonna move on
to the speakers that's a parish council
doesn't want us to be on this item no
drafts are no supporter we do have the
agent if you'd like to come forward for
three minutes please
Bethan hey and over to you good
afternoon chair members my name is Beth
Ann Haig and I'm the planning consultant
for this application I am representing
the applicant will pick business parks
for limited they are a family run
business all of whom live in the local
area mostly in war pit itself the
application before you relates to the
hybrid consent for the site grants in
August 2018 for the provision of
warehouses offices and associated
infrastructure occupiers have been
confirmed for these units and one parcel
has already been constructed and the
second to follow imminently a reserved
matters application has been submitted
on behalf of bactin transport this
section 73 application is for a slight
amendment to the already approved
landscaping scheme associated of
condition 7 of that hybrid in developed
it relates to minor changes to the
condition wording and the landscaping
scheme to the western part of the site
along with additional planting to the
southwest this amendment would enable
greater flexibility in terms of allowing
for further economic expansion of the
Business Park which relates the separate
application also before members today I
shall speak again in more detail on that
application and this is recognized that
shall be reckoned that it will be
considered on its own merits but in
summary it seeks to expand the use of
the Business Park in accordance with the
NPP F and also your emerging joint local
plan this expansion of the existing
Business Park has been driven by demand
from prospective occupiers and also
forms part of an emerging employment
allocation
the business parks expansion is also
supported by the council's economic
development officers who have confirmed
the demand for extra employment land in
this location notwithstanding this we
considered the amendments the
landscaping will result in an
enhancement to the overall development
permitted as part of the hybrid consent
with the provision of scattered trees
along the boundaries creating filtered
views from the surrounding area the
hedgerow and tree planting along the
site's northern boundary will also
assist in continuing to screen the site
from long distance views from Elms well
it is also proposed that the new
planting on the site's western boundary
along the edge of the a14 will include
native planting in keeping with the area
the application has not received any
objections from statutory console TV a
services landscape confirming that they
are satisfied with the changes proposed
overall the proposed amendments continue
to meet and enhance where possible the
principles agreed in terms of
landscaping and the provision of a
landscape buffer as part of the existing
hybrid consent for the site it is
therefore respectfully requested that
you support the officers recommendation
and to prove this application thank you
very much for your time thank you very
much spot on three minutes okay any
questions at all for the yep one so any
from the committee at this point no okay
kassimatis what's good I hadn't sorry I
hadn't picked this up before did I just
want to clarify because the officer
talked about the changes on the western
side of this site and I've just re
looking at the diagram and I just want
perhaps the agent can clarify that the
planting on the northern and I'm on page
slide 7 in my pack they're planting on
these northern and eastern boundaries of
the site are ye along the or a 45 and
Warren Lane wall pit is going to be
thickened so it's going to provide a
better buffer I can confirm that the
changes proposed
are just to the western edge and they'll
be you know everything to the east has
already been confirmed as acceptable and
has been subject to a discharge of
condition and application and I can also
confirm that there's some earlier
discussion about whether there's going
to be any loss of planting I can confirm
there'll be no loss of what's already on
site now and there has been some
planting on site around the building
that's currently been you know
constructed thank you any other
questions
okay thank you very much
so Ward members over to you yeah I will
I will say that that despite this site
being one of the economic development
sites proposed in our joint local plan
as being a site for development for
employment
use both the communities of Woolpit
and Elms well don't really support
increasing the number of employments are
increasing the size of the employment
area here because of the traffic and
although this is only for changing of
planting this change to the planting
schedule is to enable the other plots
that we're going to come to later on
today to be used so the communities are
you know don't feel that the traffic
from the employment site causes a lot of
issue this application is changing the
planting to enable the site to grow you
know it is it is adjacent to the a14 but
that Junction is a one-way only Junction
and it's fine if you are traveling
westbound to get into the site you just
slip off at that Junction any other
traffic when it comes out goes through
the communities of Elms well and more
but I will say more when we come to the
other one but it's purely to enable it
to grow yeah I mean we can only look at
this application now but we're only
being asked to talk about the
the green growth the debt on this
application I know the next one will
address that point so I do have any
questions for the ward members yeah no
no to add anything I probably should
just just say that I agree with the
comments of councilman salt and by armed
Salman will put parish councils it's
been conveyed being consistent
everybody's being consistent all the way
through there are ways to get to and
from that site that don't go through the
villages but there's no ways to enforce
them
so I'll just say I agree with what's
been said thank you
okay member so we've heard from all
those that wish to speak today and we've
heard from the ward members who to to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
Council members first thank council
having Thank You chair officer wasn't
sitting on the committee when this the
previous application was determined but
it seems to me that that 10 meter buffer
was put in to screen the site from the
a14 as you're passing and as you drive
there now of course you've got this new
building there which is very clearly
seen and and one hopes that the existing
planting wall will help to screen it in
time but it seems to me that if we're
shrinking what we've already agreed from
10 meters down to something less then
why not have a 10 meter buffer along the
a14 itself rather than just a 2 meter
hedge I mean that would seem to be the
sensible thing to do would to provide
the same amount of shielding from the
road
I really didn't see a problem with this
and I think they already are doing and
I've compensator II I'm planting to make
up for what they're taking away and so
I'm happy to go along with the officers
recommendation for approval
just to say that I'd support councillor
melon in that on page slide 6 it talks
about screening and screening units
review I think aren't I've got my
problems with the hedgerow being moved
but if it was ten meters before then it
should be ten meters along by the Eiffel
team and then if the future development
comes forward we achieved the same
objective I'm conscious of redesigning
something without knowing all the
understanding of the top and the levels
of this site this site is not just a
flat site it does have different levels
so what planting may be effective in one
area may not be as effective even if
it's wider in another in terms of what
we're trying to achieve I perhaps also
urge consideration of the view that
we're talking about it's the view from
the a14 the view doesn't really go much
further than that on the basis that
towards Woolpit
you have significant landscaping on the
land on that side and different levels
that are elevated so it's not a wider
view that's in effect a public view
beyond going past at 70 miles an hour
for the most part there are some
footpaths but they don't really look
across the a14 in that context to then
look at this site any planting is not
going to get rid of the view of the
building that is definitely there now
because of where that position of that
building is it may soften the view and I
think the question here is all these
changes remove that softening or will
they maintain the softening of those
buildings and in fact is there a gain
here in terms of your clustering
landscaping then possibly even a from
our point of view this is the office of
point of view there was a ecology gained
from clustering of landscaping in terms
of habitat but it's it's unfortunately
swings and roundabouts in terms of what
you're gaining and what you're losing
here Thank You chair well I'm happy to
second page and they're having hams
proposed which
port of the office recommendation I too
think the applicant has made an effort
to actually ensure that we do have some
green areas on this site in addition
offered to removing some of the earlier
what we agreed couple years ago but yes
I I was supported on that grounds that
they're not just going to ignore it they
are putting some more in Thank You Jed
if we're looking at this on its own
which we have to do clearly my view
clearly there is less of a screening of
the buildings and also these buildings
are going to be used by vehicles and
they're going to be used by vehicles
outside of the hours of daylight so
there is going to be a lot of lighting
there and I feel that if we had the ten
meters along the a forty instead of the
reduction that the filtering of the
light as well as the filtering of the
views of the buildings is well
worthwhile so I'm not I'm not happy with
it I do not understand why they have put
forward a lesser bandwidth of planting
along that edge I'm sorry I'm happy to
speak Oh George just yeah sorry I did
speak with the applicants before just
about the debate when to look the way of
the two meter
hedge on the road and they did say that
they could probably stretch to five
meters on the a14 site so five plus six
equals eleven you know
effectively it's it's a thicker
screening than was proposed earlier so
if members are concerned about the two
meters being insufficient it can't be
five meters it makes things a bit
tighter but it's it's deliverable okay
well we can we can do this we did last
time and it's being proposed now
accounts had own sake of our councilmen
if that's other people want to raise
that we can talk about it and then we
ask the proposal second if they're happy
that that's a condition I would like to
speak and I know counsel field last we
do you want to go first Ron they're not
coming after you yes so is mr. nerado
I'm inclined to think that two meters or
even five meters to screen the a14 from
a load
factories is a bit of an imagination but
absolutely it would we all know that
wild large leaves in some strange places
along the edge of roads where it gets
less disturbed by humans and their dogs
so you know I can see the benefit of
having a screen along the i-40 a
wildlife corridor if you like along
Route 14 and that if that were five
meters rather than two it were that
there would be some benefit I was
slightly concerned about well marrying
the the band as it was originally
proposed which I'm convinced was related
to the public right-of-way and perhaps
again some imagination about the extent
to which people would walk that route I
think reducing it from ten to six in
some areas acceptable balanced as we
showed by some increases slightly
concerned by the total remove all the
Lots alongside site one but I tend to
see that as there's an economic driver
for that which probably outweighs my
concern about removing the the screen
really I'm not convinced that amount of
trees screens buildings of that there so
as we're talking about particularly in
any case so I think broadly arm in
support of this given the increase of
the band along the edge of the Eiffel
James of God maybe no one else I'll just
give my it's worth yeah I mean I think
it's a really difficult one isn't it
because on one hand we've got the site
which has had application and came in
perform with given planning permission
but on the other hand they are asking to
move some hedging that isn't even in so
we're not taking anything out ripping
out you know pre-existing ancient we're
just being asked to move the existing
and overall there's a net gain to the
environment of what's being proposed
okay it's two versus ten in some places
but the overall site is seeing a net
gain environmentally so to me that's you
know that is a positive so for me it
will be a double win if we can have
plus the five meters I feel that
definitely that's worth supporting
so we counselor had ago council mother
has someone as their people that
proposed and seconded approval are you
happy that it is conditioned with a
following line that drum will now read
out
okay so obviously this is a variation of
condition application and I said that
would address all the proposal that's on
the plan and the plans of the documents
before you the edition with variant
variation of conditions we can because
it's treated as a new application add
conditions and so I would rather than
confuse the current condition seven by
trying to muck around with that I would
propose to add a further condition to
say that notwithstanding details
submitted there shall be a scheme of
landscaping along the a14 shown as four
meters wide on the plans to be at least
five meters wide and the detail should
be agreed and shall be implemented as
maybe a great house having a customer oh
you have do that okay does anyone else
wish to speak I think we get to the vote
on that basis so as per the
recommendation as laid out on page 193
of our papers along with the additional
bullet point around the thickening of
the hedge all those in favor of the
recommendation that's unanimous
thank you very much okay so we move on
to the next item the final item for us
today which is on page 239 of the papers
application DC 1903 503 eight five one
outline planning permission and some
matters reserved for development
comprising a mixture of b 1 b 2 b 8 uses
at lawn farm warp it over to you to
present thank you chair and some of
these slides will appear quite familiar
to you because you've just seen them
about 20 minutes ago there are matters
in common right there we go
so as explained earlier that the the
evolution of the site is that the middle
piece has already got the permission
we've just been discussing it and the
matter at hand now is four parcels to
the east and the west the application is
in outline form
with all matters reserved upon access
which is the north and landscaping now
we'll talk about landscaping in a bit
that because the schema submitted will
may have to slightly change and I'll
explain why so you've seen this already
this was the previously approved and
this is the one you've just approved
with the amendment that the hedge which
now we're here must show to you that
that's it's that bit there you've just
agreed should be five meters so this is
the new landscaping ski for the whole
site again okay I want to give you some
views across from various places just so
you get some idea about what the
landscape is at the moment and it
includes actually the building that's
already been built there on the left so
we're going from the north there across
the site this one also from north they
got the new road in from the east
looking across the site there from the
south
and from the southwest and that's it
actually tried more than that but the
two drawings which will be sorry canal
which you would give permission for
would be those relations the access and
that's covered on yeah yeah it's
basically the top left it's not very
detail but the the access is to come in
from from from the old old term gives
which role would old London Road at the
top next to the stag cafe and that is to
be secured now the landscaping as shown
here has largely been agreed and is part
of this application as well but the
reason is that the slight hesitancy
because the landscaping people just want
one or two more conditions which sort of
tweak what's been allowed and just only
protects their comments
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's a falling away unfortunately but
they basically want some advanced
planting and and one bits and pieces
basically just a slightly change what's
there so I'll put the end recommendation
another thing to say is that the floods
team had an objection which they've now
withdrawn but the commentary of that
still stays in the report so that that's
just a correction to make
yes I'm sorry yes
yep I'm sorry about my lack of clarity
there's a little get the wrong
application they look the same that
there's three limit for Sony I must look
it wrong
basically this is an outline application
for the three parcels which we looked at
in the previous yeah you remember the
the the red drawing that I showed you on
the other in fact could be look at the
first presentation I think it's but
we've got more stuff in it it's an
outline application with all all matters
reserved apart from access and
landscaping and it's for three units
[Applause]
yes butcher
yes the one with the red blocks
there we go thank you very much so the
ones we can see numbers one two and
three that this by the way it's just
indicative illustrative that that isn't
what the builders would look like we
don't know what because because
obviously it depends on who comes along
so that we reserved my supplications is
outlined but you know basically three
passes land one two three the applicant
is looking to put business units on all
of those
this is secured now this is the access
the landscaping is more or less sort of
95 percent what you see there but the
reason is a slight changes the landscape
pub play services
asked for conditions about advance
planting Landscape Management and
landscaping scheme I think we've
probably covered most that already but
they've asked for that so we'll have to
have a resubmission of a discharge just
to tidy that up but you know we're
pretty much there so what you see there
is what you get at this stage which is
the access of the landscaping the red
blocks will follow that reserved matters
one two and three yeah get outline
planning permission yeah for development
as either a B 1 B 2 or B 8 use yes and
the correction was that page 247 I
commented on a awaiting a comment from
floods that has now been it that's
actually now been receiving there's no
objection
that's correct to the consultation field
but not great though okay Castle man you
had a question I don't think you're
number one is in the right place I think
it's Oh God isn't is it sorry should be
to the left yes yes that way trying to
be creative in paintbox that happen
sorry it's to be very clear sorry number
ones there thank you for that
[Applause]
I've just I've just raised a point
I just won't clarify that John just
wants five minutes
[Applause]
you
thank you share thank you member sorry
yeah the request was basically made just
to make this present presidential bit
clarity because I showed you lots of
slides which interesting and pretty and
relevant to the first one but not read
the second one so I'm going to show you
that a few slides which are actually
relevant to this one and they basically
relate to really only one or two
drawings which are the ones that show
the pastures of land that's pretty much
it when it appears or total said you've
got the one which shows and right so
it's pretty much this basically that's
it this those parcels of land once the
east one to the west and the access so
not the landscape in other that just the
access so it's it's a very simple
outline application that that's all
we've got it just shows the past the
black and how Authority hasn't objected
so the applicant is asking could they
have employment allocations on those
parcels of land that that's all you need
to concern yourselves with odd I don't
think I've got the action planning
drawing on on there but it's here is in
your bundle
[Applause]
just to clarify ultimately the drawing
in front of you this is constraint plan
but it's actually the same as the site
location plan on page 300 so for this
this is a proposal outlier application
[Applause]
where the landscaping is very only it's
an unusual one because effectively it's
in a monk's an application that's
already been approved for industrial use
so landscaping is piggybacking on the
landscaping that's already been part of
the previous approval that access is
again piggybacking on the fact that the
access to the main road has already been
agreed and this is not proposing to
change that these are just the
additional land parcels that would
connect up to the internal in internal
road network that's already been
approved so as much as this is an
outline that says access and landscaping
those two elements are by default there
so they don't have to actually give much
detail about that ultimately we just
have outline for principal only for the
space to come back as reserved matters
for a building number of buildings
different shapes sizes whatever they
might be but this moment in time is just
for this land to comprise for potential
b1 b2 and b8 uses and whichever
quantities of that they might come
forward as it unfortunately is as simple
as that and it feels like we should be
saying a lot more and I think that's
perhaps where we struggled a bit this
morning but I was afternoon out but
ultimately it is an expansion of an
existing industrial use in compliance
with the local plan policy on expansion
of industrial uses there is a future
potential allocation of this site in
respect to the joint local plan that has
little weight at this time as we've been
discussing in other applications but it
is the direction of travel how that may
indicate your debate I don't know that's
for you and I think unfortunately this
is as much as we can say because
as much information as we have as an
application for you to make that
consideration in terms of the principle
of development thank you so your
questions at this point before we move
on to speakers yeah cancer feared that
cancer well firstly the parish council
refers to our local plan and our
emerging local plan and points out that
it states that we have a sufficiency of
employment land a question is that true
and how should I do that
I guess I asked the second one at the
moment as well the second one is the
access to this site if we think of it in
its wider terms it's from the early 14
and clearly that's short and without
particularly difficulty the exit is
somewhat different could you just
explain where emerging traffic goes to
reiax s the major route network because
this is clearly quite an intensification
of the use of this site the highways
England didn't object nor do the Highway
Authority as a responsible authorities
for those matters so that there's
there's not perceived issue there with
that in terms of the employment
obviously we've got a response from the
relevant officer in support of of the
scheme and I've evidenced in my reports
that there's a take-up and an interest
in this site so it's likely that the
units will be filled out and just to
support that in respect of the
employment allocation of the joint Local
Plan you are and the counter position
you are right we do have sufficient
employment land allocate and available
but the economic development team have
difficulties with certain allocations in
terms of take-up so there is a balance
between what is the right land in the
right locations in terms of availability
in market-led versus other allocations
that aren't taking up now when we dealt
with this application previous we did go
into detail on
the example I can give you is there's a
lot of allocations around stone market
Cedars Park and of course that's been
sitting there dormant and not been taken
up from the 1998 local plan so that
still sits in the numbers of taker
variability of land but it's not being
taken up so we have to have a balance
between you know realistic figures of
what needs to be put forward to be taken
up as well as what our local planners
sought in the past I don't know the
answers entirely to that that's why we
go to the economic development team and
they have supported this one on that
basis it's the right land for the
particular clients that we have
interested in coming to Suffolk for that
for this purpose we also have the issue
that this is an expansion in effect of
the war pit Business Park which is
running out of land availability to them
and they wish to continue growth and
this is the nearest location they feel
appropriate to them which is literally
just on the other side for them to
expand and I think these are issues to
perhaps debate as well and take into
account when considering this proposal
there was another point there in terms
of the highways issue the answer is yes
there is a direct access of the a14 one
way in order to get on to quote direct
access to this site but to get back out
to the a14 you are correct you'd have to
go back down to the holy interchanges at
the right name top Hill thank you
interchange does require a different
path for a reasonable distance and it
does include going through some
residential areas in order to get to
that interchange so there is and there
has been a historic issues around that
that have been debated previously but
it's not something that we feel were a
point of severe highway impact that we
would warrant refusal in this case thank
you chair I've got a couple of queries
and it's to do with the access are there
currently
three accesses into this site and
depending on the answer to that well
we've got they appear to be it's coming
it's colored that there are there's an
access out to Warren Lane is that is
that is that correct there's a
crossroads in the middle of the side
yeah there's actually something wrong
like there's access on to water like are
there to access it accesses onto old
Barry Road yeah I mean it's not clear on
the it's not clear on the drawing and
then so that takes me to slide seven
which has and in terms of the accesses
it would appear to me that the
difference between the two is in the key
there is an arrowhead which says access
point and it shows the arrowhead
pointing into the sort of spine road can
you get is that just an N is that just
an entry
sorry counters is that the presentation
on the first item no no no it's slide 7
like that so you had slide comes to me
very last page of the bundle
[Applause]
my apologies I'm missing those two last
pages or to apologize
ultimately the access and what the case
of resort confirm there are two accesses
which would be a on to Barry Road and
one access is on to Warren lane and I
assume that they've been the previous
access is approved as part of the first
key veins or is the access or for the
Barry Road bridges from the north there
is that's yet part of the original
hybrid the one over to the east is
existing and the new one is is to the
north what I was trying to seek
clarification on the the relevance of
the access point with the arrowhead is
that the earth is that going to be the
only way is that going to be the only
way into the site in future if we if
we're here to approve an access
arrangement and it's not clear on the
joy I don't quite know what yet sorry
that I mean that's a fair point I should
be able to give you all these answers
actually I think I just said their way
around I think that once the arrow is is
the new axis the applicant will tell you
more in a minute but that's my
understanding
do you want to defer that we saying jump
I'm going to apologize to members but I
feel that we need to go away and look at
the presentation of the information to
you in order for you to make a robust
and informed decision and I don't think
we've done that at this time so I
apologize and I would humbly request a
deferral on that basis
[Music]
apologize to the applicant but yes I
mean the problem is we're not we're not
getting a clear definition in our papers
we're not getting a clear number of
slides and we as a committee have to be
confident and the information it's
provided for us I totally get your
frustration
I appreciate you thought this to be
decided in November but as a committee
we have to make sound decisions based on
what's presented and we haven't got that
today so I will ask that it comes back
in two weeks time if you can to try and
get development control meeting be two
counts of Guthrie's Committee can we
because it is only a matter of getting
the right information together and take
it in two weeks so there's not hanging
around mypos we'll do that we'll go in
two weeks time my apologies chair should
have checked that I do apologize that's
not very satisfactory meeting to defer
to items and but we'll leave that with
the cabinet member to pick up thank you
you